Hello sweet bitches.
We're back. That's right.
[inaudible] this episode of the Joe Rogan
experience podcast is brought to you
by ting. And what Ting is, is a
no bullshit cell phone company.
They have the same service
that you'd get of you sprint,
but they have it set up where they have
no early contract termination fees,
no contracts at all, in fact, no early
termination fees. And they also have a,
an early termination fee relief program.
So if you come to Tang
from somewhere else,
they will give you credit for 25% of
your early termination fee up to $75 per
device device. This is the thing that
cell phones companies are doing. They're,
they're selling you a cell
phone for like 200 bucks,
but they're not really selling
you a cell phone for 200 bucks.
They're selling you it
for what it really costs,
but they have that money factored in to
month by month bills so that when you
try to cancel your service, they say,
well, you owe us x amount of dollars.
And what that is is because you're really
not paying 200 bucks for your phone,
you're getting fucked. It's
weird. It's kind of deceptive.
It's sneaky shit tings trying to avoid
that and they have every step of the way
done an awesome job of doing that.
They,
they charge you for what you
use. Only minutes, text data.
There's no overages, there's
no nothing, no add on charges.
And they have the best android devices
that you can buy if you want to buy HTC
one, if you want to buy the HTC
one, I think it's called the mega.
They're awesome one or what I have
with the Samsung Galaxy note three.
You got that too. Now you're
sexy bitch. So does Doug, Darren.
It's also fuck yeah bitches. It is
really an awesome cell phone company.
And again,
they use the sprint backbone.
So all the bullshit that you would have
to deal with if it was a small company,
you know, like bad service
you don't have to deal with,
but all the bullshit that
you would have to deal with.
If it's a big company you
don't have to deal with. Um,
what they do is give you an,
an ethical cell phone company to choose.
I love it there.
One of my favorite sponsors,
one of the reasons I love it is we've
had zero negative response from people
that have signed up and started using
ting. Uh, our friend Chris Ryan used it.
Lots of our friends use it.
You can use it to go to rogan.ting.com
and you could save 25 bucks off your
first ting device.
That's rogan.ting.com.
Can't say enough good things about ting.
We're also brought to you by
WHO's this today, Lumosity.
Oh yeah. We're also brought to
you by Lumosity and Lumosity is,
let me pull this up. Lumosity is, is
uh, sort of like a gym for your mind.
That's what the idea behind it is.
Lumosity has it set up.
So if you go to their website,
Lumosity has all these
different options and um,
you sign up and they provide you with
games and these Games essentially are
designed to just make your,
make your mind work and
they're very specialized. Like,
can we turn on the AC in here?
It's hot as fuck in here.
One of our camera guys loves that.
He's always dinking around with Lumosity.
It's great. Yeah. He swears by it. Well,
because you can use the Massetti and
here let me pull up their, their spot.
Get around. That's what he said. Is
that okay with you Brian? Tinker. Okay,
so I got to thinking around.
Yeah.
Steve's one of the few guys that will say
frickin when he doesn't have to be out
in the woods. Yeah. He's
this fricking thing.
I can't hear myself on my
hair from the, the, the,
there's not even a chord on those.
You're not even plugged
in. Oh wait, hold on.
We'll figure it out. That's really
not important right now though.
What's port right now is Lumosity
exercise because exercise is good for us.
Ladies and gentlemen, we go to the gym,
we take care of our bodies. And um,
new Lumosity allows you to do that
same thing for your brain. Now they've,
they've shown during in numerous studies
that, uh, lots of different things,
uh, are, are good for, uh, for
your mind, for exercise. Uh,
chess in particular is, is
excellent for it. And um,
the idea behind Lumosity is
that they give you a work,
they give you things to
do but they get it sneaky.
They design it in a way that it's,
it's like a game. And as I said,
these games are very specific
to what you want to achieve.
If you go to the Lumosity website,
you could see all the different
options that they have available.
If you go to the lumosity.com, um, you can
see like they, uh, you cleared the deck,
the get started now button,
they have memory,
all these different options from memory,
remembering patterns in locations,
associating names with faces, keeping
track of multiple pieces of information.
The more you do these things,
the more those are areas of your mind
will be exercised at tension. Um,
there's many options for speed decision
making quickly recalling recent
information flexibility,
which is a very interesting one.
Quickly adjusting and
shifting, uh, problem solving,
using logical reasoning.
All these different options
are available. Excuse me,
Kung Fu. And he come for one. There's
no Kung Fu in this, Brian Cowen.
I just get everything from confident. Um,
it's, it's basically a gym for your mind.
That's the best way to look at it and
you can also get them for your iPad,
your iPhone, there's a free
Lumosity APP. You can have fun,
workout your brain and make Lumosity a
part of your everyday routine and these
are all scientifically designed brain
games, scientifically designed. Brian,
I'm ready man. I'm mother fucker.
I'm all about sides. You know me.
Good for your brain.
And again,
lots of positive feedback from the Mosty
and I played them myself. They're fun,
they're fun and it gets,
it's like you know,
you can waste your time playing a lot
of games that don't do Jack Shit for you
or you can play games that are
actually good for your dome.
Go to lumosity.com/joe
that's lumosity.com/joe Click
the start training button
and then start playing your first game.
That's lumosity.com/joe we're also brought
to you by [inaudible] Dot com that's
o. N. N. I. T.
We are a human optimization website and
what we sell is all shit that makes your
body and your brain work better.
Whether it's things that it can enhance
cognitive function supplements that it
can enhance your immune system or
your mood or whether it's strength and
conditioning equipment like kettle
bells and battle ropes, weight vests.
We got to get you some of these guerrilla
kettlebells. Brian Cow. I know, man.
What am I wasting away to manly
up? I need, I put some meat on you.
I need the chimpanzee. What am I
looking at? Gorilla one right there.
They're awesome. Hey, you turn them my,
you turn my, your phones down. It's just,
there you go. Yeah, there you go. Okay.
We're getting it together. My voice, um,
on at.com o n n I t like,
like I said to human optimization website,
this is the best way to describe it.
We sell all shit that we find that works
and anything that we find that's good.
We wind up selling that to whether
it's a hemp force protein powder,
whether it's earth grown nutrients in
the form of grasses and all sorts of
different Greens that we've got
that you can add to your diet.
And if you're not eating the best diet
or if your diet lacks and certain things
you can add them on,
you can add a additional antioxidants,
the power green blend, rainbow blend,
all these different things like um,
different things like
spirulina and Alfalfa.
All these micronutrients and minerals.
We have it broken down to a powdered form.
Just something that you
can add to your diet.
We find things that we find that we
think are beneficial. We start selling.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t used
the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any
and all supplements. All Right, ladies
and gentlemen, Doug during Steve Rinella,
n Brian Calendar here. Cue
The music. Let's get there.
That shit.
Real good experience.
Try my day. Joe Rogan walk, gas,
boom.
Ladies and gentlemen,
in late 2013 we went to the farm of
one Douglas Duren in Upper Wisconsin.
Actually south.
It's all the same. Anything
up in Wisconsin. So it's
not like we're like, wait,
this is southeast. I love
southwest Wisconsin. No,
because there is a difference
because these guys in Wisconsin,
what they go by is that bottom quarter,
that bottom quadrant,
the bottom left quadrant. Sure. Is the,
they call it the driftless area because
it didn't get demolished by glaciers.
Yeah, that's a good point because for
folks who've never been to Wisconsin,
you think it was constant as being
like this flat area where you know,
the reason why those areas are flat
was because they got smushed. Yeah.
There's a guy I know who lives
up in the northeast and um, he,
he makes Maple Syrup and he always
makes a point to put on there from the
drifted area of Wisconsin. Like he's
trying to, he's trying to use it.
The shoes came over and smashed
it and flatten everything out.
What we reword was all hilly
and beautiful and you know,
all the landscape is varied.
That's because it didn't get smushed.
It was like a little median in
between the lanes of glaciation. Yeah.
It could've been minors. Yeah.
They just, they built it up, girl.
Good thing.
We're in Montana.
We were driving Brian's like,
oh, this is all mining large
scale mining. What the fuck are you
talking about? Minus a river through here.
Like the, at a mining expert.
Apparently I'm a mining expert.
I can tell by the topography at least
you don't really believe what you're
saying from you just start
saying something and you
just go with it for a goof.
I'll commit, I'll come in. But you know,
you don't commit with your ego. You don't,
you don't really attach on. No, just
my mind is changed all the time.
I talk about being a libertarian.
I had this guy, William Bernstein,
he's written all these books, you know,
on my podcast. And he started going, well,
yeah,
but they started giving me examples of
how being libertarian wouldn't really
help you if you, you're hoping that
your kid isn't wearing something toxic,
you know, they're, they're certainly,
when you get on a plane you want,
you want there to be an f,
f, d uh, you know, whatever
it is. Yeah. Whatever it is,
standards, federal standards
for flying. And so I was like,
yeah, yeah, you're right.
I back off everything
I've been saying here.
Well, being a libertarian up to a
point is not a bad idea. Of course,
the problem with any ideologies you
get lumped into, it's too rigid.
They're making coffee in
there at the house. Like
we used to call it,
we used to call it bulletproof coffee.
Now we call it the Robb wolf
blend. Uh, but anyway, uh,
Doug Durans farm,
you were so gracious to have us up there
to film mediator and we appreciate it
very much. And you know,
as I said on the show, uh,
you can have a different time
but you can't have a better time.
We had a fucking fantastic
week there with your friends.
You got a great group of guys that you
go hunting with every weekend and just a
great group that represents
what hunting really should be.
A bunch of cool people having a good
time doing something that's fun doing it
ethically and you know,
getting some great meat out of it.
Yeah. Got It, got it. Talk about how I
met dog. Sure. Cause it speaks of dog.
I'll just sit here quietly. Doug's
a very big man by the way. Yeah,
Doug's a good guy. A lot of
bone. A lot of bone alone.
Well I met Doug after I wrote
my buffalo book dog, you know,
wrote me a letter and usually
like letters. I don't mean,
I don't even want to say what I was
going to say. Why not? You look at it,
you know, letters. I love to get letters.
They're fantastic. You know what I mean?
But a lot of times it's like people
you can't tell if they want to. Yeah,
you can't really get it.
It's hard to determine
sometimes what they're after
and I'm sure you get tons of,
Doug wrote me a letter that made
me actually be like, I am going to,
I want to contact this person.
It was just kinda like,
I like your book and I heard this and
here's what we got going on at my farm.
We started emailing
back and forth and dog,
I don't know what year this was, invited
me to come out to his cold asked farm.
And every time it comes out,
it's cool. So it's his fault.
So I just went out there and I didn't
know if I was going to get molested.
I didn't know the guy by those big
hands. I know it's like big, you know,
Hans molested me out that place.
I left the note, I left the note.
Tell him my wife,
like if I don't call an next hours,
like call nine one one what have no
must must've been called Cazenovia nine
version of nine one one a note. This
must have been to, it was a buyer.
You already know it's like a moving. No.
So I've never done anything like that
that ever,
but I did and went off the dogs
called farm and we was real cold.
And then I came back.
I was [inaudible].
Did he meet you at the door and
a robe and a warm he picked, no,
I think he picked me up at the airport.
I did and we got to,
we got a sack of cheese curds.
I took him to my house.
He met my wife so he could see everything
was legit, that I wasn't going to
take him up to the woods right away.
That's fine. And so you became friends
and I first saw Doug on your show,
mediator best, uh, best
show on television. And, uh,
I first saw the first time that
you guys went on, you went on a,
a deer hunt and you shot some rabbits and
you made some rabbits stew and it just
looked like a, a great hangout. You know,
you guys had a really good time up there.
So when Steve said, hey, uh,
you want to come to Doug's farm up in
Wisconsin and hunt deer, I was like,
fuck yeah,
that sounds nice.
I'll go on record right now and say
that beaver might be the best meat.
Everybody your fucking mind. And I'm
not kidding. You funded it was good.
It's not as good as Venice. So tend
to add here, bitch, that little rodent
that the, can you do like a thing? You
know, you'll have a different meal,
but you'll have a pill,
but you want to have a better
[inaudible] for better beavers.
Very good.
But what I like about Venice,
as
soon as you eat it rare and you
get that taste of the real blood,
the animal [inaudible] disguised in
a meal, you're eating the venison.
I just couldn't believe how Tinder viva
was. You will, the way Steve cooked it.
Yeah. It's real tender. Yeah. I mean, you
know, you really know what you're doing.
You know,
when you,
you got to cook it a long time and you
wouldn't be able to just take like a hunk
of beaver meat and grill it. No. Well,
I've been doing that with that
pig that we shot in to hone ranch.
And that's tough. It's delicious. But
it's tough. Yeah. Even if the Loin,
even the cook the lung,
because first of all,
you got to cook it all the way
through. It's gotta be, you know,
it's gotta be like medium because it's
pork, you know? But it's not like venison.
Venison is just like so soft and
delicious. Pork is good, man.
Pork loin is damn delicious,
but it's definitely tougher.
It's definitely tougher.
Right. So how did the, the mule deer
venison compared to the white tail?
Um,
the whitetail was so damn good.
I don't think you can get better
tasting meat on the planet.
That whitetail venison that we made in
your kitchen when we cooked up those bags.
[inaudible] good man.
That's the best meal I've ever had.
I don't think it gets any better than
the way you cooked it with the butter and
garlic salt and a hot flame p. Oh my God.
We got to use butter and then
get that grill good griddle,
really hot and just cooked that bitch
for just not even like 30 seconds each
side and then beaten it up with
the beard. Smash it down. Yeah.
Smash it down with a beer.
So he cut like,
you know, an inch thick, cute,
you know, a slice of the, uh, the,
the loin pounded down so it's kind of
flat. And then when you throw it in there,
it'll seriously 30 seconds each
side. Max crackle, crackle, and then,
oh, it's so good. I was pretty amazing.
I'm the, I'd love elk. I've had,
you know, elk, that's just about as good
as any meat I've ever had in my life.
That I think, but that those, the
backstraps cook that way, it's just,
it's hard to fuck with.
And plus those deer that we shot at
your farm are so fat and healthy.
Those are some health corn
after corn fed young also.
They were also young. That's
bad there. Yes. The bad part.
Well how much different do they taste?
If they're really old?
It's a bit of a difference with you ever.
What's the oldest dear you've ever shot?
You think? Uh, that one buck I shot was,
he was at least five and a half and it
gets hard to tell after a while though.
Right on the age they
do it by their teeth.
Take it to a, like a DNR station and
they'll look at it and they'll tell you,
they say it's two and a half.
It seems like it's like every two years.
Two and a half years old because they
can't make a mistake there or something.
But,
um,
I guess that when it at five and a half
just based on the teeth and then I shot
one, uh, with Mike Arkins, uh,
or hutches he's affectionately
known by Steve. Um,
a couple of years ago that wasn't
an older deer than that and it was,
that was a little little gaming game.
He is the wrong word
because Cameron Hanes,
I don't think white tails ever gave me.
So Kevin Hanes was on the podcast and he
shot a water buffalo that was 20 years
old.
Yeah.
And he said he had a piece of meat that
he put in his mouth there at the camp
and uh,
he was practicing with his bow is steady
practice with his bow for half an hour
with the same piece of maintenance
mountains like Pac man trying to break it
down.
I killed it. I killed a blackberry that
was 17. They do a two sentence thing.
17 year old bear. How long do they
live back? Blackberries about that.
Want me to get a little older? But he
was 17 but he and I sent his tongue.
They're like the Montana State University
used to run a program where, um,
you could send a chunk of the tongue in
and they'd do a test for trig analysis
on the tongue, cause it cons like I
guess you get a good concentration.
I'm the tongue,
good concentration the shoulders.
So I butchered this whole thing and it
was funny as hell as we went down to my
room and I was in school and my
roommate was cotton fish at this uh,
bailo grocery. Okay. And
he's like, well shit,
let's just take that barrier down and
grind at after hours at work, you know.
So we go down this thing and look like
we went down there and run it through the
grinders. We had those little,
you know, little foam things.
They get meat on this stuff look like,
I mean my freezer looked like someone
had just went and raided a grocery store
cause I had it all those
foam bottom things to Saran
wrap, just look perfect man,
like stacked up like bars of gold. And
then we got done. I met, we cleaned,
you know,
we clean,
but I started wondering about the depth
of clean we did because a couple of
weeks go by and they sent me this
thing like, yeah, your bears trick.
Knowles is positive. I know you can go
in and throw the bear out if you want,
but we won't reissue you a new bear tag.
So if you,
you now have the right to like,
you can get around because it's
illegal to waste Gamey, right?
So it's one wastes law. They said you're
exempt from wanton waste on that bear,
but you can throw it out,
but we won't give you a new tag.
And I just went down and
bought a meat thermometer.
I had a hundred this bear was,
you couldn't even think about even
moving this bear. You know, I had a,
I think it was hundred is
either 130 or 160 pounds.
A fricking ground meat off that bear.
Damn. I ate it to the bitter end,
man.
They're fricking meat thermometer.
I'd be out in my yard like with
breaking bear burger meat thermometer.
I do say Frickin,
yeah.
My Mom's listening to a certain degree,
but mum was talking about
before,
before the podcast,
sorry we were saying the Steve's one
of those guys that says Frickin when he
doesn't have to,
cause I know that my mom,
my mom likes to listen to your show man.
So,
so what's the temperature
that kills chicken? Awesome.
Yeah,
we're just look this up there.
Day One 15 no it's one 55 or one 50 I
remember one 54 different gangster trick
and just change it like three you
know the Usda just lowered pork.
Really? He goes well cause
like USDA inspected pork. They,
I mean 90% of the trick gnosis cases
in the u s are coming out of black bear
meat. That's incredible. I
heard that on your podcast.
So they control how they feed pill.
They lowered the temperature on port
because what they were, what they think,
what they eventually found out is the
way people were used to be able to fatten
pigs. A restaurant slop in restaurant
slop had rats and mice in it,
in rats and mice are picking up
trick gnosis by eating flushing.
Nothing's born with trick gnosis.
It has to get it through
consumption of an infected animal.
And when they got it figured out enough
where they know what's going into the
miles of inspected pork,
they don't have any more.
Now they say you don't need to cook pork
to, it can be rare. You get a rampart.
It's like they serve it medium.
I can't believe Doug's not.
Doug's like always fact checks. Everything
you say as you say, I can't leave him
my phone off, so I'm just going
to go, uh, you know. However,
do you ever hunt wild pigs, Doug? I have
never done it. You should come with us.
All right. This is a place up here, the,
the um, to hone ranch. They're infested.
It's incredibly, I lot of them,
oh, they're everywhere and they're,
they're wild man. We were me and
Steve and the Cody, Cody, the guide.
We were walking down this road and I'm
telling you like where that curtain is,
there was some pigs duking it out.
We couldn't see them because they were
in the bush and we're sitting there like
waiting for one to pop out.
But
it's like you're in a monster movie or
something. Like there's some gremlins.
They carry it out and carry on
the brushes. Shame had no idea.
We live in a show before they come out.
I had no idea we were there.
So they were just making all this
crazy noise, right. 15, 20 feet away.
Maybe she's just plain gray.
I was hitting the Austin
and I and I,
when I came on stage,
this guy who was introduced to me and
my buddy used to be at this Delta Guy,
Delta Force Guy.
So this his buddy
was a seal seal seal team six guy.
So we've got to know each
other and talking and, and
uh, he said, look man, I'm,
I'm a huge fan of Joe Rogan's. Uh,
he and I think alike and he said,
if you guys ever want to
come down to Austin, we'll,
we'll throw you in a couple of small
birds that would be helicopters and you
guys can shoot pigs with
a bell fed machine gun.
Sounded like he doesn't know me that
well. I don't have any desire to, to that.
I like hunting pigs, but I I, you know, I
felt weird about doing it out of a truck.
Right? I felt weird about driving around
in a truck and jumping out and bang.
You don't want to pull a Ted Nugent.
Well, it looks like fun for sure.
And if it was my farm, don't get
me wrong, if I had a giant farm,
these pigs are fucking up my farm.
I would absolutely hire Ted Nugent and
pig man to fly around and shoot nuclear
weapons at though. But the reality
is that's not what I want to,
I'm not going to fly down to Austin strap
into Ellicott seems like it would be a
lot of fun,
but it might turn on an area of your
brain that you don't really want.
Turned off. My delta force buddy
literally goes, oh, I'll teach you.
I'm really good at shooting from a
helicopter. I'll teach you all about that.
A lot of guys don't know how to teach you.
I'll teach you exactly how to do it.
Not a skill set. I necessarily,
I don't really need it. You
not, I don't plan on it.
I was like, all right, well
thanks. I guess that pig man,
dude shot a pig from a helicopter with
a bow and arrow. What? Yeah, yeah.
You got to compensate to
compensate for the downdraft.
You know you have to shoot like
way over the pig's head aero drive.
That's impressive.
We shot from about 20 yards too.
I mean it wasn't like that close.
So there's 20 yards with the downdraft
and you got to like gauge it all and try
to figure out that. That's crazy. Yeah.
But he also killed like 400 of them that
day with a machine gun. I'm not kidding.
400 pigs. They've done it twice. Him
and Ted Nugent had done it twice.
They call it a pork lips. There's a pork
lips one and it was a pork lips too.
I mean it's, it's basically
like apocalypse now. That
scene in apocalypse now.
Look, look, look, look, look, look
at the screen. Look up, look up.
If you're going to eat
it, and you know, look,
he's got a fucking bear looking at him.
He's going to bear bow and he's sick
and he's going to shoot this fucking pig
from a helicopter. Look at
this shit. Look at that.
That's incredible. Boom.
Oh, that's impressive.
That is very impressive by the
way kind of bed there. Wow. Wow.
What do you expect pigs running
things in the helicopters.
A lot of shit going on there and here is
all I'm saying. Did the pig pile up? No.
No. Piglet pick looked like it didn't
even know. I've never found that pig.
Oh yeah, they got that pig.
They got them all. I mean they,
they killed 400 pigs that day.
I mean I'm not,
I'm not exaggerating when
I say 400 pixels. When you
see big like that are those,
those are not indigenous to
absolutely not. No Man there
from there. You're Asian.
They used to be all over from north
North Africans, British isles. So they,
they are, are they were they were they
domestic pigs and now they are wild pigs.
It happens a whole bunch
of ways. How do, can I,
am I loud but yeah,
every pig one.
I just wanted to get in like a geeky pig
thing. No, no, no, no. Please go ahead.
So thought it's a secret or something. Oh
No, no, no, no. I got confused like, oh,
like every pig, every pig and
whether it's in a farm barn yard,
feral, wild, okay.
Eurasian bore razorback,
whatever the name you hear applied
to it all is like sue scrapper.
It's all the same species.
So
prior to domestication by humans,
this species was found all
over Europe and Asia. Like,
I mean they were in the British isles,
North Africa and the Middle East all over.
You know, what does not Russia. Okay.
They were everywhere. Europe. Um,
we'll slowly over time different people
in different areas domesticated and
develop domestic strains
off of this, this, you know,
sue scrap off the wild pig and they then
spread it around the rest of the world
where it didn't exist.
Like Polynesians brought wild pigs to
Hawaii perhaps 1100 years ago when they
showed up there. Right. But then
at the same time you've made,
there's maintain like the actual ancestral
population in certain pockets where
you really have like the actual wild pig
that became the basis like what we got
the cow from as an animal called the oryx,
but the oryx went extinct and now
we can't look back and go like,
so what was the cow? Right?
Like what did we make cows home?
But we know in this case what it wasn't.
It still exists out there.
So we had where people
brought these domestic strains
around and inevitably they
go feral.
Okay.
So just Sodo release pigs inadvertently
released pigs in, you know,
in the new world hundreds of years
ago according to Charles. Man.
That's kind of one of the reasons
that that might've been. What,
what caused the plagues about that book?
1491 yeah.
I might've been the reason that they,
they did a lot of the native Americans
died in such massive numbers from typhus
and all kinds of, cause they gets it
because like pigs share so many diseases.
But then at the same time what would
start to happen in the late 18 hundreds
early 19 hundreds is people started
going and catching the ancestors,
like the ancestral pigs,
undomesticated ancestral pigs,
taking them as wild creatures and
cutting them loose. So in California,
lot areas in California,
you go there and the pigs resemble and
there's some integration probably from
domestic strains, but they
really like, you look at them,
you're looking at like what we
now call like a Eurasian board.
They got long snout razor back. I mean
everything about them like straight tail,
everything.
A bottom screens like wild pig and you're
kind of looking at like what is the
wild pig in other places you can
go on there just as wild what?
They're feral domestics. Oh okay.
How big is the, is the original bore?
How big do those guys? They get there, you
know, it was funny there. They get big,
they get, you know, they'll,
they'll shoot ones in the wild.
That can be four or 500 pounds. Wow.
I mean that's, I think that's pretty,
that's like a big board,
but they get to be bigger than how
much of that is muscle. Oh yeah.
But that pig was such bs, that
whole Hogzilla thing. Total BS.
Well, it's a perspective issue
for sure. Well, yeah. Well guys,
like he sees one of these Hogzilla short,
he goes,
I sold that guy that pick a week ago.
[inaudible] he turns up and he's got
a picture up in the back of his truck.
Which guys? A few of those
Hogzilla is out. Yeah, those
are domestic strains. Okay.
And every hogs, like every Hogzilla in
his past was sitting there on the court,
was on a corn crib. It's not unusual
to make an 1100 pound domestic.
So that guy before by livestock
than any almost put together.
Let's hold that makes sure up again.
So that guy basically just
cover that thing in dirt.
No, listen, you can take it.
The mastic, you could
take a domestic pig. Okay.
Leave them intact or whatever.
Give them all the corn he's
gonna want and you're going to,
you can make giant pigs.
Then all you do is you take
it out and do a pen to place,
turn it out on the pen location,
go shoot,
and then you go like hunt it in quotes.
Yeah,
that's interesting. And they're just
buying them and putting out there.
Now that thing has hair all over it.
You know Nugen runs those things.
He runs things where that he runs like
these little pen facilities where they
got like,
like suppose the wild pigs in a pen.
Dairy and people come out and pretend
to hunt for them and it's like one of
these pods. Zillow's that turned up.
It wound up, there's a picture of it.
There's a picture of the guy with it in
the back of his pickup. That's hilarious.
Well, we would want to be that. Some
guy bought it for his kid to shoot. Oh,
cut it out. He cut it all out
on some little parcel of land.
But when you get a wild boar that's
500 pounds, how much of that is muscle?
They got a high yield man.
Speaking of that, a lot of
game animals, like 40% yield,
I mean pigs out of high yield.
I mean on a wild one it's gotta
be 50% yield Manga Vanilla
and I, okay, we shot this
pig. It's five 15 okay.
5:15 PM it gets dark at five 30 and
the pig is probably like 200 pounds.
We take this pig and a, I shoot it and it
rolls down this fucking hill. I'm going,
this hill is like really steep.
I mean Riddick like hard to walk
up like really steep to just walk.
You kind of have to crawl up,
right?
So we have to figure out
how to get this pig out.
We try to drag it up with this guy's cord.
He tries to pull up this truck,
but it's a good word for that
road. Yeah, it's of course
the court keeps caching on rocks and snaps
and snaps twice. So we're like, fuck,
what do we do? So we're trying to figure
out what to do. I said, frick. Yeah.
So Steve says we should cut it.
We should. We should butcher it,
cut it up and then walk up the
hill with it. Yeah. But Cody,
the guide says you guys should kick
it down to the bottom of the hill.
There's a creek bed there and you'd be
like pushing it the whole way and then at
the end of it as a street and uh,
I'll come get you this treat.
Well I guess he was a little
off and it's fucking typography.
I didn't really recognize how
fucking far the hill goes down.
Right where we were. And by the
way, pushing a 200 pound pigs.
I like it has wheels. We
tried it. We tried to push
this thing for like, I dunno,
like two or three hours. First of all, I,
yeah, you'd roll it just wind up in the,
in like some hell hole.
And then we wound up in the hell
hole somewhere down the stream.
So we're down there. It's,
we're at the bottom now.
We're nowhere near close to the road.
We're fucking miles from the road. Okay.
And we've got this pig and it's pitch
black out. I mean in pitch black,
you could see stars in the sky.
We're hearing twig snap behind us because
there's only like 50 mountain lines up
there. And to hone ranch, it's
one fucking waterhole. They have,
he told us we have pictures
of 16 different mountain
lions at this one waterhole.
It's a huge ranch.
This ranch is shit.
This ranch is 270 plus thousand acres.
Yeah, California banned Lion Hunt.
Yeah. So let me got, you know it was a
lot lighter. They're all over the place.
So Steve says, look, we gotta,
we gotta cut this thing up.
There's no way we're going to get this
thing out of here. What? Cut it up. We'll,
we'll,
we'll put it,
throw each throw half over our
shoulders and we'll just carry it out.
It seems most reasonable, right? We're
cutting this thing and Steve's joking.
Oh there's line. Mine is, I hear a
line cause we hear like snap crack,
we hear like twigs snapping and we're
out there with blood all over our hands
pulling hearts out of this
fucking that same client base.
Then we have to carry it
and we carry it for what,
another two fucking hours
or something like that.
And it's starting to get really
sketchy because it's super steep.
It's dark as fuck.
Can't see where we're going.
I'm slipping all over the place
and I'm like, I'm going to,
I've twisted my knee up, kind of
fucked up. Not Bad, but I'm like,
I'm gonna fucking break my neck
like this is, this is kind of crazy.
We finally get to the
bottom after he like,
who knows how many fucking
hours Cody needs to stay.
We want them hang in this pig up.
But where we came to just so happened to
be an ancient shack that they had that
they had built during prohibition so
that Hollywood people could come up there
and drink booze.
They had a still build out a native
timber with fire fireplaces made out of
native rock. The most amazing
places. I'm going to put it,
I'm going to F for folks
who listen to right now.
I'm going to throw photos of it on.
I'll throw it up on Instagram while we're
doing this podcast. Incredible. Like,
he can't even imagine the work that
went into this place, man. Yeah,
it was really fucking, it just ran.
It's just into the ground is not here.
You can't even,
you can't drive to it.
So it's run down and just sitting
there and it's beyond. There's no,
there's no saving, Huh? Yeah,
it was really incredible.
So you get to that thing?
Yeah, we just hung it up off
of, we hung it off overhead.
Like hanging over a drain. Yeah. This
is the, this is the shack. So, so,
so let me ask you this. Are there any
danger of a mountain lion coming in?
Well we were armed.
No,
but I'm going to be coming and getting
the meat over night. No, I mean I,
any danger of getting attacked by a
mountain. Oh Man. In the last, what,
80 years in the last 80 years has been
like maybe more than 80 years has been
six or seven line fatalities and Mommy's
and Washington state yesterday and 11
year old girl shot a mountain line
that was going after her brother.
You want to talk about it?
A little gangster cat? Yeah.
Pull up that story. Hold on.
11. Yeah, this was, yesterday was a 50
year old cat. Apparently the cat was,
or 50 pound cat.
Apparently the cat was like real skinny
and they were saying that was probably
just starts hurting. That's
a small cat. Yeah. Yeah. But
I mean, it kind of drives me nuts when
people act like lions are, you know,
any more dean, I mean,
will you said after all,
they're not as dangerous
as yellow jackets are.
Ground nesting Hornets scared all
of them too. So they're out there.
We're going to go fuck themselves. They're
all through with the, with the, I mean,
they're feeding on these,
these hogs at this place.
Paul to gotta be cleaning house
on man. You know, come on,
you can run them down to,
oh,
look at this little girl and
they got a picture of the cat.
It's fucking little girl. She's 11
years old. Shot a fucking mountain line.
That's shot. Shot that mountain lion.
No, there's no, no, no. It's a picture.
There's a picture of the glass.
Like it must not have been too stressful
of a situation. Well, the girl,
um, she's apparently she's a hunter
and her, her whole family hunts.
And so she knew how to use a gun.
Like there's a picture of her with a
raccoon that she killed that's available
online. She knows how to use a
gun. And this rack, this, uh,
this fucking panther was coming
after her brother and she shot it.
That's a crack shot for an 11 year old.
That's great. A fucking mountain lion.
So find the article. Can I go back to
the machine gun out of the helicopters?
Yeah. Cat. So needless to say,
well maybe I will say that
that's not something that I,
that I have any interest in, but what
I do have an interest in is, uh, uh,
talking about what good is,
how good a shots you to
where I was just amazing.
My favorite topic right now, well,
the cashmere killer. Yeah, exactly.
I've learned from Steve Vanilla,
I learned from the best well in.
And what was so gratifying about the
way you guys hunted in the way you were
there and in,
and I'm just thinking about Brian and
how that deer came down through the woods
and you know, he's honest and he's on it
and it's like, Yep, I've got it. Boom,
one shot down. It went. That's in
my book the way it ought to be done.
They call me game. I of course, it wasn't
that far away, but I appreciate it.
You know what, man, I'm telling you.
Ever since I started practicing archery
and practicing with bows and arrows and
I've been doing it for a few months now.
You really like about shooting Amy with
a rifle when you can actually rest the
rifle down on something
and look through a scope.
God Damn is that easy in comparison
to a bow and arrows effective way more
effective.
It's fucking hard.
Like to aim at something more than 30
yards away with a bowling out. Yeah,
especially like a live animal matter.
It's hard to stand with a
scope and try to shoot. Yes.
I don't think you'd ever do that anyway.
Right. Well, I've been doing that.
I've been doing that.
The range. Really? Yeah.
I've been doing almost all of my
practice, right. Whole different ballgame.
The sitting, even, even sitting,
doing almost all my practicing at the
range locked into my shoulder because I
remember when we were, um, we
were pig hunting. I had one shot,
the one pig that I missed.
I was trying to rest up against a
tree and I'd never done it before.
I've never taken, I was like, I don't know
what I'm doing. This is a weird thing,
but try to put the gun up against a tree.
It felt awkward.
So I've been practicing just like this,
just sitting there like this
with my elbow up against my body.
Practice with your knee up. Yeah, just
it's way, it's a whole different thing.
Just even I did a few standing. It's
fucking hard. Yeah. I don't know many,
I don't know many serious hunters
who've been in a lot of situations.
You take even a hundred yard
shots without having a rest. Yeah.
Yeah. I probably wouldn't matter
what it, than less somethings like
heading out. Well that, yeah, generally,
yeah. Generally you'd, you'd want to,
I mean,
free hand shooting out to certain
is real deadly all to a close range.
But you know, you imagine the
trajectory of that thing and you know,
and if you're an inch off that 10 yards,
you're two inches off at 20
yards and on and on and on,
and then you run the risk of an
injury in the animal. So, you know,
you gotta be careful. Yeah. Or not
are not good. You don't want to take,
when you're hunting, do you get
the chance to shoot, uh, you know,
as we would off the bencher when we
were just practicing in our place.
So you do need to be able to, you
know, adjust and lean off of something.
And that was the other thing you
did when we first got in the blind.
I was thinking you were kept pulling it.
I mean, I just don't do that, you know,
pulling the gun up and pointing it out
the window and he's just like pointing in
different places and
I'm like watching him.
Okay. Why is that bad? No, no. I mean it
was, he was moving a lot, does move a lot.
I'm Connecticut and I kept
trying to look through,
I go through these weird games
where I'm like pretending I'm,
I'm whore and I'm looking through my scope
for the enemy is wrong with you cause
I'm cause I'm talking
about here's all the war.
I'm pretending I'm such a bitch.
I had,
I had a warm thermos in my tummy and
I had all those heating pads. I stayed
very toasty. But the point
is is that he then, you know,
took the rest, made the
shot twice. Yeah. And uh,
uh, I mean shot two
different deer and, and
I guess what I was going to say about
shooting is that if you are in a situation
where like,
uh,
I don't know if I missed a buck on that
last day that we hunted and jumped him
and he ran. And you know, I had,
I took like three steps down the hill
and he wasn't very far away and cleaned
mist. And, um, but I will, I
practice shooting that way. I mean,
I don't shoot a lot, but I
will actually practice, you
know, free hand. But I'm not,
you're right, I'm not gonna shoot a
hundred yards or 150 yards at something,
but 50 or 75. I mean, I've killed
a lot of deer are really close.
Well, because they get up and running.
How when you get that deer in your sites,
you know, like everything
goes away, right? I mean, it's
just like, it almost feels,
it's almost like that's the rush.
Thinking About Your Chore
List and now Instagram, do
you have an Instagram? No. Oh
No. What is it? Meat
Eater. Tea Country TV. TV.
It's Steve's at Steven Rinella. Okay. Um,
I've been doing videos on my
Instagram was Brennan show.
We're not asking about you are we? I
was going to, well, I'll show it to you.
Let it remind me. I'm not
really interested. Oh No,
you are. I want, you know,
I want to make, I want to, I want
to have Doug talk about like the,
like the,
the like hit
the deer on his place and all that.
But one thing that's just really bugging
the hell out of me is last time I was
on here I uh, I said
something wrong. Oh, okay.
I was talking about to hone ranch and I
said they have to [inaudible] which is a
native elk in California.
It was like,
you know the Elgar divide like rocky
mountain note to Lee's Roosevelt's,
no saying they had to release which is
the native California out onto home.
They don't, there are some real close
to there but those are rocky mountain.
Thank God you cleared that up because
it's been bugging me nuts. But no,
it is important because
the Tulio Carne is big.
The rocky mountain elk or unusual for
that area and the only place in California
that has them is to hone ranch and then
they bought the free from some guy had a
captive facility into Boston free
50 years ago now run wild out there.
It's incredible.
We only got to see a few of them but we
tankers man huge because they don't have
a winter problem like a lot of the elk
in the mountains too. Like, I mean,
there were snow while we were up there,
but it's not snow where they don't
have food. They're getting food.
They're probably putting fat on right now.
He's fucking elk were GI
in there, Joe, we saw,
we saw some cows and we saw
one bull from a distance,
but Steve picked up a shed that was like
a fucking limb on a hundred year old
oak tree. It was, it was huge. It
was longer than both of my arms. No,
they, they, they, I mean they regularly,
you know, what do they weigh? Oh,
thousand to 1200 pounds. That's a
horse. A horse. They're huge out there.
I should tell everybody that's interested.
You can hunt at that place. They were,
so they were kind enough to bring us up
there and let Steve and I hunt there.
But you know, anybody can
go hunting there. You hire
a guide and you pay for it.
It's not cheap, but it is a game rich
place. If you're good a pig man, you know,
I mean, that's, yeah, but the most of
that, can you, can you find elk up?
There are no,
yes you can.
They do it. Yeah, you can. And they do a
very, I think that they're saying they,
I mean they kill like honestly,
they kill a handful of elk off
that place every year. They kill,
they kill thousands of pigs
out that place every year.
It's really aggressive dude. Really
aggressive pig calling. Please.
I heard you can't shoot your way out
of a pig calling pro. They picked up.
They keep a handle on
me, but they, they, they,
I mean throughout the year on
average they're killing like many,
like several a day just to keep,
uh, just keep grips on it. You know,
I look at Gels, look at that. That's
the peg that is, that looks good.
It's got a long snout. Is that
a, is that a wow pass. Very raw.
It's very Russian looking Eurasia.
Yeah.
To hone ranch. If you're in La and
you're looking for a place to hunt,
that is a game rich environment and it's
only an hour and a half outside of La.
Real Nice folks who run that
play. Dude. Cody plank is
solid. Yeah. Very, very nice.
Cause I'm like Tom, I thought there were
solid, very nice guys, both of them.
We had a great time. Cody was your
guide. He took us out, showed us every,
I mean the place is gigantic. We saw
it at least 50 deer. We saw at least,
I don't know how many fucking pigs.
Hundred easily,
easily a hundred pigs in the two days
we were there, we saw about maybe seven
or eight elk. We saw Turkeys, we saw about
a dozen Turkey hill. We saw everything.
I got a buddy in New Mexico whose body
works out there like at an administrative
level out there.
And he kept telling over the years,
and this guy hunts like a lot of,
you know,
serious back country honing my friend
in New Mexico. He kept saying, man,
he gotta go out and see this to homeplace
you would never in a million years
guessed that sitting there never.
And then you'd get up way up
high and there's like Cedar,
it's like there's a ton of
different bio types there.
You know you get way up behind her
was like cedars and it just like,
you couldn't imagine that you can then
like drive out of there and go down to
lax and fly. Yeah an hour and a half.
I mean it's crazy. It's so bad ass.
Not only that, it's a private ranch so
there's not that many people up there.
How big is not fence to like when you say
we told you you weren't paying for it.
Acres millionaires accordingly.
If he's not,
if he doesn't get to talk he doesn't
listen. No, I'm not good with numbers
but I do want to get something because
I didn't want to bring up something like
management, you know, so they,
they work really hard out there.
They work hard to keep a grip on the pigs
because pigs it hard on ground nesting
birds for instance,
there used to be a lot of quail out there.
They suspect and turn be a lot of
turkeys out there and antelope,
they suspect it.
They've seen a,
they suspect that one of the things
might be going on with quail out.
They're just pigs, you know,
cause they hammer eggs.
They like the ground nesting birds. So
they do a lot to do that. But in Japan,
but I want to bring up,
I want to bring up deer like oh I want to
talk about deer in southwest Wisconsin.
Look at that place. That's the
pig ranch. Before we talk about,
here's the other thing
was the two pictures.
You had the one of the Hogzilla and that
looked like a domestic pig that, I mean,
yeah man. We used to raise
on the farm when I was a kid.
We had shorts now as opposed to the one
that I chose the erasion and that was in
multicolor front ones.
But then you go to New Zealand,
I hunted pigs in New Zealand and every
one of those pigs looks like something
just walked off a farm.
They look,
they look great and then you throw them
in the crick and get the mud off them
and they'll be like black
and white and brown man.
Crack is correct if it has no crick
crack a crick as a crick according to
Patrick McMahon is if you can
find automotive parts in it.
[inaudible] it's clean.
It's a creek.
And this is most certainly quick,
like if you went up and down you'd
find a spare tire making it a crip.
But the other thing about
pigs too is when I was a kid,
we had picked out you were here.
I keep trying,
I keep trying to tee,
I keep trying to cheat it ours time
and I'm in the media. Give him a break.
I'm trying to t dog off
talks about his damn phone.
So let me talk about the
farm for a minute please.
Uh,
we raise pigs when I was a kid and uh,
had,
you know,
there were chickens on the farm at one
point we had dairy cattle and all that
kind of stuff, but the pigs were
never anything. When you say domestic,
you could see where, where as soon as the
fence is open, they're gone. You know,
they aren't,
they're not like Holsteins or even the
herds that you saw or the angles that I
had there that'll,
you know,
they'll come around and he'll just
stand by and stuff. And pigs were,
they were pretty quick.
[inaudible] not here.
I'm going to eat that song
really naturally.
Far As let's just go to the woods.
Right. And, and his, his uh,
Steve's comment about, uh,
about the eggs or the quail and the Turkey
makes complete sense because they're
there, what are we calling it
written around in the written,
the routine,
the routine take about
and, and that's what they do. So they're
always, you know, tearing stuff up.
So anything that's a
ground nesters going to be,
of course it's going to be in harm's way.
So it makes complete sense that that's
an issue much against the pig. And one,
one sow pig has, you know, 16, you know,
between 10 and 20 little
ones. Each time they, they,
I wonder how,
I know Craig out multiple year.
Meanwhile a deer's putting off wondering
to fall back to the darn deer again.
Rights activists feel about pig hunting
because that is clearly an animal that
you have to control their bodies.
Yeah. Like that's the thing
in one went to New Zealand.
All the animals in New Zealand are not
all, not all the animals, but you know.
Oh yeah.
The game man was around and
introduced and there the um,
the guys that like to hunt there are
always complaining about the greenies,
you know,
and their complaint about the greenies
in New Zealand is the greenies want to
kill all the animals. Oh,
that's hilarious. They
want to preserve something.
Why preserve native?
They want to preserve native ECO systems.
So like these damn greenies would like
to get up in the helicopters and shooting
all the animals. The opposite.
They're greenies are done. Well,
you're allowed to do crazy shit.
They're like,
you can have Canadian goose with a rifle.
Right? Oh, you do. Lot crazier now.
I mean there's no, they have acted
well. They have active programs.
They have active programs where there's
like government shooters who are just
shootings. They have no predators.
Well, they can't introduced predators.
They can't do that. No, because they
have, they have the sheep is a huge,
well they didn't like sheep caused
a major problem with pollution.
Apparently paid their take on is
they're not going to introduce a little,
they're not going to have to gas.
Methane gas like grabbed me. Great.
Literally was a problem. Smog was a
problem in New Zealand. We looked this up.
It was a prophecy from, from there. Yes,
from their forest. From the methane gas.
But I don't think methane forms the smog.
It does some form of smog and it's,
it was a major issue in New Zealand.
Methane gas was a major smog problem
and I don't know if it still is.
I doubt they put devices on their asses
too. You know, I heard the equipment,
they put the bags so dark.
This place you got right.
But I'm curious about this lead
sheet. Flatulence. Oh my God.
Solution Law. I believed him
because he said look it up. Yeah.
Other times he just says
he doesn't bullshit. No,
I just count and talks a
lot, but he doesn't bullshit
now. I know what I'm saying.
That's incredible. And that amazing.
Well that's an issue in California too.
I knew it was an issue in Pennsylvania.
Parents used to live in Harrisburg and
there was an area that I used to drive
when I was living in New York.
I'd drive to Pennsylvania.
There was an area where you could
not roll your fucking window down.
You couldn't do it. You wouldn't die. My
newer pools, just like the little ammonia.
Yeah. So bad. It's stocked so horribly.
It made you not want to eat meat.
It really does.
And when, when we, I went to China, uh,
when I literally in 1985.
Okay. I think it was, in fact,
it was 1983 I was with my family
once the mainland of China.
And I dunno if I were to tell you this,
there's one,
we go to a restaurant in Canton.
Where is that doesn't matter. Oh,
you told me about this.
And underneath the restaurant we're pigs.
So underneath the restaurant were pigs.
A lot of pigs.
The pigs were eating the shit that,
so you,
you would take a dump and it would come
down and the pigs would eat the shit and
then, no, we don't eat all
the slops from the restaurant,
but they were eating human feces and
then they were eating those pigs and then
they're reading those pigs.
The roads are that joke. It's
like that joke. The punchline is,
I had lunch with them two weeks ago.
Monday, no joke. No, no, my mom.
But that was that. That
was always like, no,
I wasn't that always
the job of up of pigs.
Didn't they eat really grow stuff
like my dad, my dad is always say,
you lay there long enough and you'll
eat you. That was like is, oh they will.
That's the number one animal that kills
off life livestock that kills farmers.
Oh really? Yeah. Guy died recently.
They say he might've had a heart attack,
I think it was in Washington state.
He fell into is a pigsty and
they just fucking devoured him.
They found his clothes, like
parts of his clothes left. Yeah.
They say that the mafia in Italy
would fit in that movie snatch.
Remember the movie snack
and it's in the deadwood.
They spoke to the cargo. That's right,
but it's true. It is. There it is.
There's a scene that lead to your head.
Everything. Huh? There's a scene.
Clean it up.
That guy was awesome to
do is feed them two pigs.
You've got to start off
the picks for a few days.
Then the side of a chop top body
would look like Carly to a peer side.
You've got to shave the edgy a bit button
and pull the teeth up for the sake of
the piggies digestion. You're cooked
through this afterwards of course,
but you don't want to go sit in
for the pig shit now though. Yeah,
they will go through bone like butter.
You need at least 16 pigs to
finish the job in one setting,
so be wary of any man
who keeps a pig farm.
They will go through our body that
weighs 200 pounds in about eight minutes.
That means that a single pig can consume
two pounds of uncooked flesh every
minute.
Hence the expression as Grady as a plague.
It is that guy freaking [inaudible].
Those are great character that
what a great vines realize.
I've never seen that movie. I've never
seen snatch. No. Really. Our scene,
fucking tremendous
guy. Ritchie's masterpiece. Wow. I got
to see that. That's a great movie man.
Lock stock and two smoking barrels.
That's the you,
so you never saw the Brad Pitt character.
I saw lots of that where he's a boxer.
Yeah. Accent. That was what
people say. See? Oh yeah,
Gypsy is, what's the word? Cock.
Cockney what's not cognitive?
It's like I talk to me.
He's not tipsy accent.
They have like a jibberish sort of a
way of talking where you really can
understand them. It's really difficult.
They use rhyming slang and stuff. I've,
I've heard it and you can't understand
the thing they're saying travels
worldwide. I won't lie to
you. I travel a great deal.
What were we talking about right
before the podcast started?
Where we're talking about said you
have to bring this up on the pilot.
About about,
um,
so I did a podcast today with a guy from
crack.com Dan O'brien wrote a really
funny book called how to fight presidents.
He literally took every president in
the history of America to see who is the
baddest ass,
who is the one guy you wouldn't want to
fight and who would win in a fight if
they were pitted against each other.
It's like it's in some ways the greatest
book of all time. And like I said, I go,
this is the, this is going to be
the greatest podcast of all time.
It was the funniest thing because we got
into a heavy heated argument about who
would win in a fight and you got to put
a cup of presidents up at the top of the
list. You got to put a blanket cause he
was renowned for his physical strength.
There it is.
It's about he fought vampires to right.
Well he did it but he used an ax. He
used an ax, but Abe Lincoln was six,
four and had, what's that? That
disease where your arms are longer,
you have really long arms, like longer
than your body had crazy England.
And he was, he was known to be really
strong and, and very, very tough.
Like he was,
I'm sorry.
I think you also have to think of
people that lived during that era.
There were a lot tougher. They grew up
doing everything with their hands, right.
Building things. Andrew
Jackson was a gentle, I mean,
he committed a little something called
genocide buck. And you talk to historians,
they're like, well, he,
he killed a great deal of native
Americans with extreme prejudice. So He,
I dunno what, he's not a,
I wouldn't, that's a strong
word. It's a strong EU thing.
It's a strong lung disease.
I don't think disease transmission counts.
I agree with you.
Is that what lead he did?
He was a soldier and did,
I mean he was, uh, he,
he clearly probably killed a lot of
men with his bare hands. I would've,
I mean that was barons, but certainly
with a gun or a knife. I mean,
he was a pretty warlike fella.
Yeah. And in fact challenged.
He had a number of duals.
Historians are actually,
he got shot and live most of his
life with a bullet in his rib cage.
Shitty guns back then, but he had
it cleaned through. He had there.
There's a debate how many duals
he actually hat when you have,
when there's a debate on how
many duels [inaudible] president,
you're a bad mother fucker or you're an
idiot, right? Keep getting a Doula. Well,
he got shot because he let the
guy take the first shot. He goes,
take the first shot guy shot him,
and then he shot the guy and live that
way for the rest of his life. He had,
he had a gaping wound that would
cause problems periodically. Anyway,
take the first shot. You got to
Andrew Jackson, who was six to
probably George Washington,
six four who was a tough guy.
George Washington was six. He was,
people weren't that big that I know.
He was a giant.
I'll tell you six for Jesus Christ.
George Washington was as big as George
Washington could've beat dog gone money
on Doug. George has wooden teeth.
He's got a fucking goofy wig on.
You pull that wig off,
he's all insecure. Yeah,
you build that wig off. He's not
gonna know what the fuck to do is.
You're going to search for his wig.
You kicked him in the Dick.
Next thing you know,
you're pulling out his wooden teeth
and beating the shit out of him.
There it is money on.
But then there was Lyndon Johnson who's
also six four but Teddy Roosevelt who
practice,
who boxed,
wrestled and practice judo with the
guy who brought you out to the United
States,
the first judo guy,
and was obsessed with all things
wrestling and fighting. He was about five,
10 and very thick, but very sickly kid.
Died of heart disease, had a weak heart.
So I don't know,
my thing is Gerald Ford played football
and could have played for the bears as a
middle linebacker.
That says a lot when you play in the NFL.
So I might have to go with,
we had a huge discussion about this for
a good hour with Brian Cowen show and a,
it was a good time. I got Lincoln.
So no, that's not what you're taught.
So then he said, I said, what about
Barack Obama? And he got quiet.
It Dad's a comedian, really good
guy. He got quiet and he said, well,
I can't be like that. You
know, I, I'd rather leave that
alone. I said, why? He said,
well,
I tried not to,
you try not to include any
living presidents because
it caused too much trouble.
I said, what do you mean? He said, well,
I went through sort of a thing about how,
you know,
Barack Obama's not that tough a president
and it'd be easy to kick his ass.
And uh, you know, I was doing
it tongue in cheek, you know,
you'd probably kick him here and he's
kind of skinny and you could take,
and he gets a call from the secret
service because he posted it as a blog.
You Post it as a blog on
[inaudible] dot com well,
he said the reason the only blog that's
not up there anymore is that because he
got called down to the federal building,
I believe. I think that's what he said.
It's on my podcast.
And he had to go line by line with these
agents on what he meant by what he was
saying. And he was like,
well, I said, you know,
I said Dick Tornado instead of a penis
cyclone because it's kind of funnier.
He was trying to teach them a humor.
These guys were totally fucked with us.
He got all nervous. He was
like apologizing. He made,
they made him take it down and it was a
chapter that was somebody from the book
I believe so that I was like,
we live in America now.
You have to be careful
when you've threatened the
president you will get called.
But guys, guys, come
on, come on man. I mean,
and he took probably can't,
they probably can't.
Well they tend to probably no way to
go. Like yeah, they probably knew.
Of course he's joking,
but there's a thing that you
set in motion a certain size.
What happens because they said we will
subpoena everybody that made a comment on
your on blog,
like
kick his ass and, and, and, and Dan
said, well it's a bunch of 14 year olds.
Have Fun with that. And the, the main
guy had called him first. He goes, look,
I know you're kidding.
I know you've got a sense of humor.
You've got to go down and talk to
these guys. It's just the way it is.
Powell had shotgun animal in my bag
one time going through the TSA line and
Anchorage and they were like, you
got shot, go in and I am on your bag.
And I'm like,
Hey,
so I know my brother or I didn't know
my brother were Ptarmigan hunting this
morning. I kind of like, and they say, and
it was like, of course, that makes sense.
Of course we know that that's true. Yeah.
But no, because you did this, we know.
Got to act a certain way and run through
a whole set of things and it's really
annoying that you had that shit
in your bag. Dumb ass. You know,
same thing happened to me when I
was going up to Alaska last summer.
I had three rounds,
three or six rounds in a glove pair of
gloves that I just threw in the bag at
the last minute. And, um, yeah,
they, they took that real seriously.
They get sniffing around.
There you go.
There's the no live rounds
in your bags or a night.
I was, I had no idea. That
can be a problem. Yeah. But
without the rifle or a gun, they shoot
him on. What was I going to do? Hit uh,
hit them with a nail biter
but you can't even,
you can't fly with a shotgun choke.
I just got a new icon.
Choke.
That's the thing like what a shotgun
barrel on the end of the barrel.
Like there's a monitor,
there's constriction or not.
And so when you talk about like
you hear the term full choke. Okay.
Full show cause like tightly constricted
anyways. Now they make shotguns.
I have a thread now they made shotguns
threaded end. Oh yeah. Full choke partial.
Cause I always go for the full
chunk sodas like improved cylinder,
modified cylinder, full show,
ski joke. So they make a trend,
they make it threaded fitting.
They make a threaded thing on the end
and you can put in variable chokes. Okay.
That one in the middle has
a variable show. Okay. Why
do I have a boner right now?
That's so weird. You call the one on
the right as variable choke. Oh, I see.
So yeah. Fix. All right. So anyways,
you can't fly the choke and I
just think that's ridiculous.
But then I started realizing what have
you in like 20 of your buddies all has
some dinky little shit gone the part
and you're all waiting in line to get on
the plane. That's right.
You're like, well,
it's just a barrel just to barrel on that
day. I was like, I just got a trigger.
That's why. That's what dad
does. National Security.
They always talk about now with three d
printers that the threat of being on the
print your own gun. That's a big, yeah,
I was just talking to someone about
that. Yeah. I got pulled out a line, uh,
flying to Washington DC from
Madison or no, from Green Bay, uh,
with,
uh,
some friends lived in the DC area and
it was going to help him with a patio.
They say, we'll pay for you to come out
if you want to help us with this patio.
So I'll put that out there if you ever
need any patio work, that kind of stuff.
And I was late getting to the
plane and so I didn't have a,
I just had both of my bags. I'm was
going to check one and I a Mason's chisel
in a stone hammer in there. Okay.
So you can't go on there and say,
I'm thinking to myself, oh, Hastings
chisel and hammer stone here, man.
Yeah, you're big enough to
actually kill an entire lane,
which has two weapons. I know
it's weird. Arbitrary about that.
Like you can't bring a pool cue on,
but you could bring a skateboard.
And if I had to fight a guy and he
had a pool cue and I had a skateboard,
I will fucking, skateboards are
really hard to break in there.
It'd be hard to land a shot.
Well,
the pool cue on a guy who's got
escape or by the trucks pull cues,
break defendant, pool cues break. They
break pretty easy. I've seen guys break,
get mad at her, a shot and whacked
her stick and snap even the,
but then you can break the bus.
So he could put,
just put some kind of rod inside there
and make it really tough pool cue.
You could do that.
You could do that,
but I'm assuming they're going to actually
understand where you're calling from.
I mean it's gotta be, but they'll
take to let you take deer antlers on.
If you've covered the times,
you can wreak havoc.
I put [inaudible] run show gave
shit through the fucking now,
by the way, by the way, at the head,
there was this story about this huge,
this huge,
um,
there's a story he played in the NFL
for a long time as a defensive end.
He's a giant man. Are you going to
name drop? No, I don't know his name,
but he got crazy on the plane. What?
Cause he had an, he has, but he's bipolar.
He's a, he's not tried to pull the
door off the plane. Mid Flight.
So he's trying to pull the door
off this child. He's 270 pounds.
All muscle played in the NFL
and nobody knew what to do.
He was having an episode finally,
I think instead of attacking him
because everybody would have died,
the stupidest talked him down to sit down.
He ended up going to jail for it.
But I think about how scary that would
be with a giant trying to pull a door off
a plane a little bit. Yeah.
Yeah. That's scary shit man.
Because if you get a plane full of
cowards, you really fucked. You know,
if you get a plane full of cowards are
people with asthma or something and you
didn't go real situation going on now,
but cowards bowling's nothing probably
emboldens the playful of cowards.
Quite like so new.
Trying to rip the [inaudible]
fear overrides the other
feeling how long it takes
to open up a door. It doesn't take that
long. And you know it's actually ready
vacuum and turning the law. You can't,
you basically can't do it in mid flight.
Physical power.
Has Anybody ever done it? No. I'll never
heard of it. You can blow a door off,
but you can't. You know, so,
Oh and also everything Brian
Collins says just getting validated,
unless Brian writes makes all these
[inaudible] USB drive flow is a little
documents. Here's a really cool
piece of trivia. Here's a crazy,
I just found out this is
a crazy piece of trivia.
If you shot a 30 odd six at a plane
window at the cockpit window, it would,
it would stop it. The window. It stopped.
I didn't, that's a problem I should say.
I mean yeah cause to stop.
Good.
Cause you could potentially hit
something at four or 500 miles long.
That's how thick it is.
It actually would stop a really fucked
is that they go down because of birds.
Like that's a real common sucking
in the engines. Yeah. Yeah.
That dude to land in the Hudson.
Do you know how they keep birds away
from runway hunters up higher peep they
poisoned them and shoot
[inaudible] what do you
mean to say is like no,
in addition to that? Well for [inaudible]
say no the fucking guys. Right.
Well, in addition to that,
in Afghanistan for example,
when you know where they went,
how boom in Kabul and then come to heart,
where were they? When they, when
they're always taken off, right.
So how do they keep birds away?
They had a lot of them. Do you know
if they do take one guest? Come on.
Think that's kind of why I
did better than taking guests.
I just named a litany. But you're, but
you're a liar. So here's the thing. No,
you're right. But here's what they
do. They get Peregrine Falcons,
they get to peregrine falcons and they
literally fly the Para Peregrine Fly
Falcons in a circle around the earth
and they stay the fuck away from, yeah,
they stay away from the,
from the, from the Falcon I,
which was surprising to me that all
of them to see the Peregrine Falcon,
they're like,
I want to stay away from that.
And all the birds stay down
[inaudible] transmitter on the falcons.
So Nolan's sucks at news
engine. Well I don't, but they,
the guy had it on his arm
and that's how they did it.
So that's pretty surprising. I didn't
know that time of European contact,
we had x number of whitetail
deer living in this country
and they were nearly
decimated at a point in time.
Now we have 100 million deer, far, far,
far more white tail deer live here
now than at any time in history.
Doug will jump in at any point.
When Doug was a kid,
what was a big deal,
Doug?
It was a big deal to see
a deer around our area.
Wow. I mean, he would run
home and tell him hello Dan
car and drive out and mean you go out
in the evening. I mean, we still drive,
get out in the evening and drive
around and look for deer. But you know,
you're really disappointed if
you don't see any. But, uh,
you went up north hunting my grandfather.
MMM.
Yeah. According to my dad
who never makes anything up,
uh,
hunted deer would go over to the Baraboo
hills on the edge of the driftless area
and that was the only place that were
white tail deer. And I, as a kid,
I just don't remember
seeing that many deer.
My Dad used to go up north deer hunting
and they would bring dear back from up
there. But then when I got to be
14 when I was in, um, you know,
in high school and started
playing basketball and whatnot,
uh,
we couldn't go away for opening weekend.
We went to north the
first couple of years,
so we'd go up north and hunt like
crazy to see one or two deer and,
and not get one. And uh,
so then when I was 14, um,
we started hunting on the front and
I'm like, wow, look at all these,
I got a deal right away. Um, but,
but you're absolutely right
that the management of the,
of the white tail deer in Wisconsin
is a real success story, even though,
you know,
newspaper articles and,
and whatnot to the contrary
that it's been such a,
well,
some would argue too much of his success
cause it wasn't till I was like the,
for the last few years, you couldn't
shoot a buck until you killed a doe.
Right. Um, we had a thing called
earn a buck. In fact, we still do.
After you shoot your first buck,
um,
Kinda got into that whole thing about
how many tags can you get. And it's like,
well,
in our area you can get as many,
you can choose as many deers
you have bullets for. Um,
but you're absolutely right and
there's such an adaptable creature.
My sister lives up in the town, a
city called ash caution on it. It's a,
they live kind of on the
edge of town on that. Really,
I'm that much to the edge of town, but
there's a little a quarry there and uh,
armory and whatnot.
And they have wildlife problems there.
A deer and Turkeys both.
Um,
and they've had to do a whole
thing where they brought in,
they bring in snipers to shoot him
because there were a bunch of bow hunters
that said that they would do it.
Well, just let us come in and we'll
do it. We'll be like, well,
why would we have the public do it
when we can pay government [inaudible]
government officials as a
private private snipe? Why?
Why would we have the public pay to be
able to do it when we could just pay
someone else to come in and
do it real discrete and quiet.
That's what's going on
right now in the Hamptons.
The stories coming from the Hamptons,
they have a huge deer problem in the
Hamptons where all these multimillion
dollar estates and China houses up there
and they're going to hire snipers. Yeah,
they're dicking around with trying to
give the deer a conscious contraceptives.
Higher numbers of dollars are going to
spend trying to eradicate these deer with
birth control and with snipers.
Wow.
I had a landscape business in door county,
which is the thumb of
Wisconsin and you know,
so it's a lot of folks from
Chicago and Milwaukee and Madison.
We have places up there and one person
would want to raise hostas and all these
exotic flowers and whatnot and the
next one would want to see deer. So
exactly. I mean you pull into places and
then you'd be laying right in the bed.
My mother in Connecticut,
she spent like literally like,
I don't know how long planting
this beautiful garden.
I remember getting like flowers
and then the minute they bloom man,
literally it was just a decimation of
deer came in and just ate them all.
My mother went to the store to go find
a crossbow cause I want to apply a
crossbow and the guy goes for what?
She goes,
cause I want to kill all the deer on my,
uh, on my property. She had a garden.
It wasn't a big, it wasn't like
it was a yard and the guy goes,
you can't kill a bunch of deer. It's
not legals. He goes, I don't care.
I'm going to kill the deer.
And then he had to explain to
her like what kind of line.
It was a little more involved
or more involved in that,
but she literally was going to kill,
you know, she never shot across pope,
but she was gonna. She thought
it'd be easy. The client
and door county, uh, uh, older
woman that um, like the deer,
but she really liked all her,
her different gardens and whatnot as well.
And somewhere along the line she got
this idea that if you buried wine bottles
upside down, sticking out of the ground
in a perimeter around your place,
that the deer would hit those and then
they wouldn't, they wouldn't come in and
for blow their mind and they'd be like,
no way am I going in there
glass. So she was, yeah, so she was,
she was drinking a lot of wine to
surround that place too. But uh,
which I may have been a part of the skews,
but you'd go into here what
they got going on in this area.
Where are we on it in November is you
know what's going on in the state of
Wisconsin,
a bunch of other states that you have
CWD they cause chronic wasting disease.
Chronic wasting disease is the
deer and elk aversion of mad cow.
So it's with, with Kyle, we say
mad cow or like with Jacob. Jacob.
And then you have, and
sheep scrapey deer and elk,
they call it chronic wasting disease.
So how are they so far they haven't
found it. And some people say like,
we wouldn't know yet,
but they haven't found where
any human has contracted,
you know,
hasn't contracted mad cow from,
well it's Jacob Christ felt in the
human, has a contracted from deer. No,
it hasn't happened yet,
but a lot of states are taking measures
to try to get a handle on this and
they're,
they're taken where you can't move some,
some states you can't move deer bones
from other states into the state.
You can't move to your
bones out of the state. Um,
one thing that could be
driving the transmission of
this is just having way too
many deer. Another thing that drives
transmission of, of, of deer diseases,
bringing them into like an unnatural
proximity's is baiting dear.
So you go out and put a bunch of corn
down, you get eight deer standing,
their nose, the nose, the nose.
I'll eat eating corn. It's not,
they're not configured in a way that's
really replicable in a natural setting,
like dear tend to graze a little bit
further apart and they're not sharing.
Swapping spit quite so much
in Wisconsin.
Got The CWD area where they're
trying to Cole knock back numbers.
So we're on the northern edge of what
they call the CWD management zone.
And actually right before I came out here,
I check the map to see how
close the deal they test your,
obviously they test here
for um, and it, the,
the latest ones are about three miles
south of the farm. So next year, um,
everything's getting tested. Um,
you'll send the heads in to get tested.
But actually what they did, the friend
of mine actually has a check station now.
And um, I, and I didn't know that,
um, this year, but uh, she's,
she was trained to take the lymph nodes
so you don't have to take the head and
do all that kinds of stuff. So it's
much simpler process. But the thing is,
no one really knows what it
means yet. Well, right. And,
and they have all these recommendations.
You guys remember when,
when we were butchering, we
were, other than the front legs,
everything was boned and you're staying
and you stay away from the spine and
that's where you get it, right? So if you
eat them, if you get the meat, you know,
the preop,
like the pre ounce concentrate in
the brain and brain and spinal fluid,
spinal column.
So even if it was a deer that had it
by not, you know, messing with the
spine and whatnot, you'll be okay.
That's the,
okay. Because the way they were bumping
it from animal to animal is, you know,
it was like bone meal. So yeah,
that's, that's how your transmitter on.
And one of the big arguments against
Penn raising livestock to have like full
hunting facilities is that CWD jump to
our wild herds from captive animals.
Um,
I think the ground,
the ground zero was in Wisconsin or
Minnesota since the first time at jump.
Yeah. Uh, uh, south of us. And if
you in Wisconsin. Yeah. So, um,
on the,
on the south side of the Wisconsin River,
and it was interesting
because you were a specular,
had some information that I hadn't
heard before about how it had been
transferred and whatnot,
but raising a whitetail deer as a,
uh,
as a,
as a domesticated animals
actually become fairly big.
One of the big things is antlers.
Yeah. Cause he can grow bigger
antlers if you've given them all this
and whatnot.
And you know,
it's in Wisconsin that is regulated
by the Department of Agriculture,
trade and consumer protection.
Whereas wild dude,
so those are domesticated deer in wild
deer are the purview of the Department of
natural resources and the
two don't. So the, the,
the deer farmers want to
stay in the Department of
Agriculture and the DNR would
like to have a little
more control over that.
Yeah.
Because if you cause like the,
the wildlife that's held in the public
trust is that detriment from a lot of
that deer.
That's exactly.
Well, yeah. I'm, I'm always, I'm actually
amazed in the two times I've hunted how,
well,
and maybe I'm wrong about this,
but how well the government does in
conservation efforts and in policing,
you know,
the whole hunt game.
Look what happened when we didn't, man,
you got up in the 1920s 1930s and we will,
we were not just running out,
I mean we are gonna run out
of a lot of game animals.
I mean it was on the horizon that we're
going to lose many, many species of dogs.
We're going to lose the wild Turkey.
I'm going to lose dear. Lose the elk,
lose the big horn sheep all
to hunting on, on on. Yeah,
the perfect storm of things.
Unregulated market hunting being one of
the, I'm not trying to downplay the role,
one of the principal factors, but it
was going on in conjunction with a lot,
you know a lot of habitat
destruction north things, but yeah,
just shooting it and selling it.
Unregulated.
Hunting what animals and then not even
like not regulating what kind of weapons
you use. You could set charges,
pack with ball bearings up in trees.
The blow roosting turkeys out
of the trees. So he's just like,
it was a free for all.
And it was Daniel Boone man.
He killed 108 hundred
16 bears in one year.
One time. Hold on. The big on the
Big Sandy and Kentucky. So wow.
Unregulated.
Mark did cause a lot of damage when it
came to 1920 to 1930s that's when we got
this idea where we were going to get
aggressive and we didn't do it a second,
you know too soon.
And we came up with certain things like
we have hunting bag limits seat like a a
ban on the sale of game wild game. So when
you're, when you go into a restaurant,
when you go and do a wild
game restaurant in the US,
you're getting imported meat or you're
getting farmers where they're taking out
taking d, You're raising them
on the farm, killing them,
run into as a livestock model on wild
animals and settlement and you're not
getting like,
I didn't know that hunter killed while
game unless they're importing it,
you know? But then even now they used to
import a lot of stuff from New Zealand.
But even now, most of that when
you, when you're getting red deer,
which is like most,
the most common Venice and sold in
restaurants is red deer often from New
Zealand,
sometimes from Scotland.
Even the stuff from New Zealand
now they're just, it's just farmed.
They used to sell some wild stuff, but
the, but the industry's changed so much.
Is there an animal that is still in
danger of being extinct in this country?
As far as like grizzlies or not?
There are many,
many animals that are endangered
or become an extinct. But no,
not no game animals, no game
animals. There's a game animals.
I mean most of them are expanding or
stable and the states under mandates.
So there's lots of,
there's like little understood.
I mean there are many like frog species,
all kinds of things that
are in huge trouble.
Bird species that are in big trouble.
But right now with game animals,
I take that back.
Not in the danger of being extinct,
but in danger of being big trouble.
Sage grouse because of many
manufacturers. Um, sage grouse are,
are hurting right now and are,
some people are starting to I at four
for endangered species protection.
It could have. What about
eagles? Like there's, I mean,
they're not a game. Animal.
Eagles are kicking it. You mean
Bald Eagles? They're the new cro.
Oh Man. Yeah, that's, that's
a huge success. The new cro,
that was something that was really
a big deal to see when I was a kid.
Bald Eagle. We have them come through
the farm all the time. Ddt Man,
all they had to do. What about
Golden Eagles? Hold on a second. DDT,
DDT was killing eggshells too thin. They
crushed, crushed, crushed her own egg.
So that was what they were using for
pesticides. Just turn it, turn it shit
around so fast. Yup. Yeah,
yeah. Wow. Not like would docs,
will they realize the wood ducks?
We almost thought we were going to lose
woodchucks. Well they realize with darks,
old dead trees like wood ducks are cavity
nesting doll. It's kind of a funny,
odd idea.
But this wood duck like lands and damn
tree walks into a hole in the tree and as
the cavity Nestor, various,
you know, factors at play.
We lost a lot of these big old cavity
trees. We people brought the wood duck
backed by.
This guys are like the hunt darks,
going out and building these little
things to look like a mailbox on a post.
We had a couple of them up.
Well we weren't by those places.
But then even in our forestry program
on the farm, we leave wildlife trees.
Um, and Mark O'Neill, you mark them with
a big w and just got all the guys in it.
If it's got a kv one,
it's not worth a shit anyways probably
cause you're gonna cut a nude and it's
gonna be rotten wood to wildlife habitat.
But you make these fake ones
by putting a mailbox on a pole,
take some sheet 10 and tack it on her.
So raccoons can climate and all
of a sudden, like overnight, boom,
wood ducks are back.
No pesticides, certain
pesticides, uh, being, uh, a
problem with bees. Are they doing
anything about that? Same with
colony collapse disorder. Yeah,
they've got real issues. So
funny you bring that up. Um,
one of the things that I'm going to do
when I get back to Wisconsin is too, um,
there is in the, in the
latest farm bill, uh,
some funding for encouraging
farmers to plant bee friendly
Forbes in their, in their
pastures. Um, I again,
right by where Ryan and I were hunting
out in that open field, there's,
I planted about two thirds of an
Acre of, of pollinator habitat. Um,
what does that mean? Like, like bring
even flowers particular, yeah, pretty,
you know, so that there's, there's flowers
at different stages of the season. Um,
you know, how much is two thirds of
an acre going to do? I don't know.
But since I'm putting so
much of the farm back into,
into a conservation reserve program,
which means we're planning it to
grasses and Forbes and whatnot, um,
when I get back,
I'm really going to look into this and
cause a lot of the interesting things,
a lot of like Alfalfa and clover and
those are things that deer like too.
And Turkey's like and other wildlife like,
and then during the flowering time,
of course,
the Beazer part of it,
but it's kind of cool in this most recent
farm bill in the conservation measures,
it's,
I mean it's not,
it was like $3 million for the entire
driftless area or the Midwest. I'm sorry,
not just the driftless
area, but um, you know,
when you start to parse that up into bags
of seed that people would go into the
other,
I'll overseed my pasture with it or yeah,
that mixed in with my
CRP and whatnot and hell,
I'll do that without them paying me to
do it. So That's interesting. You know,
what I've heard is that there's also
some connection to genetically modified
crops at some crops have been genetically
modified to make them more resistant
to certain bugs and that this is
what's fucking up bs is that well,
truth in that.
I think there's truth in that.
The GMO is certainly
could have a part of it.
We were talking about her daughter at
your daughter before and my daughter who's
17 who's taken the
biotech class right now.
That's one of the things that
they've been talking about. And I,
my hackles go up when you say GMOs.
And interestingly,
she kind of talked me down from it because
she's, you know, on both sides of the,
of the thing. I honestly
think that the, um,
pesticides probably have more to
do with it than anything. I mean,
we're using insecticides on everything,
you know, and the idea that, you know,
in our area you saw it who were,
the crops are essentially two things,
corn and soybeans.
And so you've got these
monocultures and you know, there's,
and they're all, those are all GMOs.
Roundup ready. That's the big, you know,
the big thing, what does that mean?
Roundup? Roundup herbicide glyphosate,
which is a nonselective herbicide means
it'll kill everything. They recommend it,
but not to cry because it was regarded
as having the toxicity of coffee.
Yeah.
It's
like if you, if you went to
drink the stuff, you know,
but [inaudible] been what that's been,
what people have said
for a long time later.
Roundup has always been the friendly
herbicide because doesn't it, when it
hits,
it does his job on the plant and it goes
into the plant and the plant dies down
and dies. The, the, um, doesn't it grow
itself to death in some way or like, well,
that's right, but the chemical then,
um, doesn't translocate in the soil.
There's chemicals, herbicides and
whatnot. I was just spraying one, um,
a couple of days ago that I'm real careful
with it. I'm out in the woods spring,
um, uh, basal bark applications
to kill undesirable trees.
And you're careful with that
stuff. Undesirable trees. Yeah.
What kind of trees are undesirable
in this case? Red Maple.
I remember the woods where we walked,
where all it was just the big giant
trees where it opened up and it was,
I'm trying to regenerate red and white
oak in there and they're red and white
oak are a sun loving
species, so they, they,
that some needs to hit that
hit the ground. They're real.
They w oaks don't grow real fast either.
And the first,
their first two or three years,
they spend all their energy sort
of building the root system.
And then after about their fifth year,
they'll take off.
But in between all this stuff has
grown over the top of them, the, um,
the,
you know,
the perennial stuff like burdocks and
that kind of stuff don't seem to bother it
too much. Um, because they're
gone, you know, quite a bit.
But it's the shade of the,
of the other trees. So it's a fast
read. Maple is a faster growing tree,
so they'll get up over the
top shade out the oaks,
and if you don't control that,
the red maple,
not sugar maple red maple will take over,
kill the oaks off.
And now you've got red maple.
So were wrong with you.
Get into the deer thing too though.
I mean the deer effect on red. Yeah.
And the deer, the deer,
the deer effect on, um,
on red and white oak is they
like white oak acorns. In fact,
they prefer white oak
acorns as do turkeys,
but they like to browse
on red oak seedlings.
So the oaks just don't stand a chance.
Part of the reason why we're
trying to kill somebody dear.
You wanted to know why,
why you love Red Oaks?
Don't like the bagels in the
driftless area. It's the area
drifted the glaciers and mining really
flattened area. I'd keep going down the,
in the driftless area, it's a pathway
from migratory songbirds. First of all,
and migratory songbirds come up the
Mississippi River and that's that.
They're traveling long distances,
the oaks or one of their favorite
nesting areas in that sort of thing. So,
um, oaks were a big part of our
forest for, for quite a while.
Um, because of things like
fire and that sort of thing,
which we don't have anymore.
So what's happening is there,
the percentage of all kinds
of landscape is a lot less.
So when you have an opportunity or what
we're encouraging land owners through
this network of forest land
owners that I work with,
when you have an opportunity
to regenerate, okay, you
have a good spot to do it.
They're not every spot where
oak is growing now isn't
necessarily a good spot to
regenerate oak,
but when you have a good spot to do that
you should because it's disappearing
from our landscape and
it's affecting wildlife,
it's affecting all those sort of things,
but also the migratory songbirds.
So it's really interesting
how it's all kind of together.
It's fascinating the
management aspect of that,
that people have decided
to take a concerted effort
to make one plant grow and
make another plant dye
and encourage you know,
you to reduce deer population because
the deer hammering the seedlings,
it's an, it's an advertent effort
to correct an inadvertent wrong,
I mean so much of our self as like we
have, we live in disturbed ecosystems now.
Like in debt that disturbance brings
about the radically transformed, you know,
biome that we live in.
Right. Why do we have so many white tail
deer? Well, because we have all these,
we have everything that they need.
They have crops that we have crops.
So we have covered, we have water, we have
all that. You know, you made the comment,
um, I don't know if it was on a
podcast or when we were just talking.
You said they're like, deer here
are so different than the mule deer.
They're like farm animals that you have
to shoot. Yeah. It's kind of, you know,
that's kind of right. Um, yeah. Deer,
Geese, Turkeys, crows. They really,
you know, because of farming.
There they are. And there are some,
there are so many of them. So to my mind
it's sort of a bonus, but the, you know,
that we have that,
but at the same time you can't let it run.
You can't let any of those species
overrun things. So it's uh, you know,
it's a balancing act.
And so on our 400 acre farm,
even in just a little over 200 acres
of woods, I have like 16 different, um,
uh,
areas where we're doing different kinds
of management based on what is there
that a hundred years ago you wouldn't
have to, had to have done that.
We didn't have invasive species, which
is one of the huge issues that we have.
You know, you get to close turn off, you
buy that stuff called multi flora rose.
Um, invasive species
are a big problem. Um,
encouraging the different kinds of,
of,
of trees and therefore encouraging
different kinds of wildlife. It's all in,
it's all a part of it. Um,
unfortunately, you know,
Brian was saying before that
he thought that the, uh, uh,
the government agencies are
doing a great job and you know,
I'd probably get sick,
I'll probably get skewered for this,
but I think that is the case.
The Department of natural resources in
the state of Wisconsin does a heck of a
job. They're horrible at public
relations, but they're really good.
They're really good at,
um,
counting and understanding numbers and,
and you know,
what are carrying capacity
and it's an inexact science.
It's not our friend pet Stephen,
my friend Pat Dirk and writes about this
a lot and one of the things he says are
our hunters out there who
think it's like a bathtub.
Like you can turn the water on to get
more deer and then you shut it off and
then you can pull the plug in.
That's not really the case.
And you'll hear grumbling hunters talk
about how the dnrs killing all the deer.
Well, I, you know, honestly, I've never
seen the department of natural resources.
Yeah. Every, yeah, every state's got it.
So you get like a department of
fish and game department, fish,
wildlife and parks or
the government agency that's controlling,
um, hunting in each, in each place.
Could you elaborate though
when you were saying this,
cause I want to know how are they bad
at public relations? Um, when CWD start,
when CW, the chronic wasting
chronic wasting disease, um,
was discovered in Wisconsin. It's only
really only been in the last 12 years.
Let's, yeah, in the
early two thousands, um,
one of the things that they came out with
was we need to eradicate the disease.
In order to do that, we have to kill
all the deer in this area. Well,
if my farm was in that area, I'm not
going to be, I'm going to say, well,
I don't know if we need to. I mean you
said there's a couple of sick dear,
do we need to kill all the deer?
And then they kind of went into this sort
of heavy handed government attitude of
here's what we really need
to do. Um, whereas you,
you probably realize this, that
you were here, you weren't,
we weren't really following
government regulations on our farm.
Look at that deer,
deer,
that's a deer with CWC dam and
that, by the way, by the way,
by the way, Mr [inaudible] that
came from from farms, correct?
Like that came from Deere farms,
right?
Well, I came across some
livestock. It's alive.
It's a Eurasian livestock
diseases cross to, um,
got into some wild herds or I'm sorry,
got into some domesticated deer.
Hurts.
Yeah.
Domesticated deer kept kept captivities
captivity but was not originally on a
commercial facility. It wasn't like a
guy out there trying to sell fo hunts.
It was a research facility and there were
deer coming up and smelling knows what
the deer inside his research facility.
And that's what they think.
Correct me if I'm wrong. This is, this
is everywhere on the web for you guys.
Whoa, Whoa, whoa. Hold on a second. That,
so the, the, there's a fence between the,
the domesticated deer and the wild deer
and they touched each other somehow or
another. There's a fence. I don't,
I really don't have knowledge
of that because it's, I, I've,
I've asked a lot of questions about where,
how did this start in Wisconsin?
There's a lot of people don't seem to
have the answer and you don't get that
answer from the government guys.
And then you talk to the private guys.
But if you go into southwest
Wisconsin, there's a area, um, um, uh,
county there, and the town that
I'm thinking of is Hollandale.
And if you look at a CWD map, you'd
just, it just, it was just massive.
So there was a, you know, sort of
ground zero, um, and I don't know
how many states is it in Novo?
Well, it's in Illinois now too, but they
speculated this came from out west is,
I mean the thought really well because he
had been in, there you go. Yeah. Yeah. So,
wow,
that's crazy.
Our farm is up where the CWD or some
other states have had some CWD farm is
where the,
the top part of the D is on CWD behind
the thing and they're right in there.
Yeah. So that's where it, um,
so that's six, 10 in 2005.
And if you were to find a, uh, a
more recent map in the DNR has,
has those out there. Um, it, it, it's
just spreading and it's being spread.
And I,
this makes sense to me that there are
so many deer in some areas that they're,
especially young bucks are getting pushed
out because you know,
big daddy doesn't want them around and
so they get pushed out and they're the
ones who are um, there you go.
This scary disease man. Um,
we don't know.
But that's the thing is like we don't
know if it is or not because there are all
manner of wildlife diseases,
some imported, some,
some that have always been here that
periodically come through and wipe out.
You know, 70, 80, 90%. You got
blue tongue tularemia in rabbits,
all kinds of things like now.
And then you get a bunch of animals,
the animals get sick, a ton of
them die. You have some disease,
disease tolerant individuals
and it comes back.
One thing we try to do when I say we,
like I worked for the government.
One thing that,
that our wildlife model generally tries
to do is take out some of the peaks and
valleys, you know, um,
I'm impatient with people who get to
easily overly critical with state fish and
game agencies.
Whereas I think in the United States
of America do a pretty phenomenal job
considering,
and when Doug talks about like bad public
relations is you make some management
decisions and the way guys find
out about the management decisions,
they open up the rule books. There's
no explanation of why. It's just like,
it might be that, you know what
dude, you can't kill. You know,
used to be able to kill a doe.
Now you can't kill a don't county.
Everybody gets really mad. And they
could go down and be like, why is that?
And there'd be some really well thought,
scientifically based decision about,
wow is a bad idea for this year to do it.
But people just see it and
they go like, oh, it's the,
it's the right wing is the left wing.
It's the Cuckoo's, you know, [inaudible].
They don't really even bother to really
put forth like why we're making these
decisions we're making and insurance
companies, insurance triple a,
I shouldn't point out one individually.
Insurers are generally a force for
wanting less Deere agricultural interests.
I'm generalizing agricultural
interests with Jerilyn,
your force running less Deere guys that
want to go out and hunt or generally
forced one more year.
But I heard that the,
that,
that the biggest pollution source of
pollution I may be wrong is not even cars
or anything. It's agricultural runoff.
Like that's, that's the big threats.
Hog farms are bad, right? Am I
wrong about that? Fertilizer,
phosphorous in the fertilizer going
into the water source, you know,
those sort of things
that cue nitrates in the,
in many years in the water yet in that,
that's a huge concern. I mean, yeah.
Can you tell that story about that trout
stream in that God had all that frozen
knurling and out?
Can you tell that story?
Well, so, uh,
south of us there's a class one trout
stream and a guy names like titties,
trout fishing. Yeah. Well for
southwest Wisconsin. Anyway.
What does that good, good. Oh,
titties Michigan in Michigan for two.
That's an expression. But
it's hilarious. Titties lady.
Like that car is Cherry. That stream
is titties. I haven't heard that.
I've heard Cherry. Yeah. But
if it's chuck full of fish,
if you're feeding your
car with chuck this,
you'd be like brushing their titties
in Michigan. Apparently in Wisconsin.
It's nobody says no Steve
or analysis titties.
He's he like my wife's
nickname, man. I'll pull it up.
Saved like that on my phone.
Nothing wrong with that. So, uh,
what are we talking about?
Oh, tell him the story about
boat. Like a, just a, like a,
like a occurrence, you
know. Okay. So what happened
that was, uh, their, their uh,
storage maneuver, storage, uh,
regulations and whatnot in times when
you're supposed to spread manure times
when you're not, and then we get these
huge megafarm, it's like, you know, again,
when I was going to be,
you saw that barn and that milk cows,
we milk 40 cows in there. Well, 40
cows in the barn during the wintertime.
You know,
once a day you'd go out with a load of
manure and spread it on the fields and
you know,
it wasn't that big of a deal.
Now you're talking about
thousands of cows in a barn,
liquid manure going to these huge storage
facilities and there's semis driving
this stuff around. Well, in
this instance, this wasn't,
this was like sort of a medium
sized Pharma but 500 milk cows.
So the guy was doing things pretty much
right, spread manure, but he spread it on,
on frozen,
uh,
snow and ice and whatnot with a buffer
strip back from the trout stream.
But it rained and melted into the trout
stream that went and wiped them out.
All those fish went tits up,
such as I was still tits,
tits up. So did some justice.
I'm learning so much. Yeah. So,
you know, one would argue, well, let's,
we should be regulating that. Well, right.
But then there's the concern that
while we're regulating things to death,
and this sort of goes back to the
deer hunting thing, um, you know,
in the eighties and nineties, the deer
population went, just peeked in Wisconsin.
Is just huge. I mean, you saw, you
saw, you thought you saw a lot of um,
do your opening day and by the way,
you didn't,
by the way, by the way. Yeah.
I mean there were days when I would
see 75 year opening day they would come
running through a group would come
running through. Yeah. Um, and,
and it's not good though, right?
No, it's not good. That's the point.
Somewhere in between is,
is there's a balance.
You guys get pretty used to that guys
get used to it. That's exactly right.
I'll go out and sit and while I
want to see it here, when I go out,
I'm on the shoot
on every time. Well, you know, then they
call it shooting and killing, not hunting.
You know,
you
know,
it's interesting during this podcast I
put up a picture on Instagram or that pig
that I shot and I have had a fucking
tidal wave of people mad at me.
Is that right pig? Not cool man. Dude.
I mean,
I don't know how many of them are cause
you shop all day because you shot a non
native animal that these guys have been
eating their entire fricking life in
bacon form and had the audacity to like
actually come face to face with the
animal. Yeah, I mean the, the, this,
the fucking comments on, on Instagram,
it's quite hilarious.
Just tap tapping way
over their self righteous shit.
Heads come on.
[inaudible] you need a filter thing.
Like where you can filter out everyone
who's not vegan and then like at least go
like, okay the vegans, you know,
they have some moral right.
Some consistency, you know,
I don't even think it's sad.
I mean it's just like people just
don't want to see a dead animal.
They don't want to see it.
It's this weird disconnect that we
have that we talked about on your show.
We this weird disconnect that people
have about their food and they feel,
even if they're, they're meat eaters
and if they're wearing leather shoes,
they feel like they can take the moral
high ground and say there's something
wrong with you posing.
Especially because apparently people don't
like the fact that I'm smiling. I say,
you're going to me. You're
glad you're, aren't you glad?
Because it just got all kinds of pork.
Yeah, I'm happy. I'm happy. Grin.
I got 200 pounds of pork and a I shot
at at five 15 we have 15 minutes left in
the day. It was the last chance
of romance. No, you should.
You should apologize for being
happy about having a windfall of me.
It looks like a good shot. It was a
great shot. I'm sorry, I'm picking,
never knew what was going on. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I shot a pig perfectly.
160 yards and I didn't cry and I'm crying.
I'm coming over to eat some of that
today. Come on. I've got a smoker, man.
I bought a beautiful western smoker.
I'm brining the pig as we as we speak
and brining a ham. Nice. Why don't we,
why don't we farm venison
the way we farm cows?
Paying attention.
[inaudible] I know we do,
but I I,
but we don't do it a lot is
what I'm saying. Like, well,
I'm surprised that we don't,
it's such good meet.
Why don't we do it as
much as we do with calcium
problem with,
um,
one thing is prom with
disease transmission.
We've been talking about and there's the,
there's a thing where there's an
aesthetic issue and there is that,
I mean there's, there's a
demand for it. The demands met,
there's arguments to be made before.
One of the arguments against it is we
have like an obligation to protect native
wildlife. Right. All right.
So keep it native and there's,
and there's a heritage of having these
animals as wild animals of some people
feel, myself included, is some
people feel is that there's a,
that these ants, there's a sacredness
of these animals as wild creatures,
you know, and we try to like
foster their wellbeing. And
from a practical standpoint, um, you know,
I don't know how much you guys noticed,
but there's some fences around the, the
barnyard and whatnot at our place there,
four strand Barb wire fences and it kinda
mediocre fences is what I would put,
the cattle won't bother.
They just walk over to him as
long as cattle got hay in the,
in the band and whatnot is what kind
of walk over and you might get the
occasional ones like ah,
I think I wanted to get out today.
Yeah,
like the one that destroyed almost ended
your marriage cause they your wife's
guard. Yeah. Well I left the gate
open so it wasn't really that,
that almost ended your
marriage. It's fucking shaky.
Is that ground you're saying?
[inaudible] it was,
yeah.
Well it was a beautiful car,
Huh? He was a hanging garden.
There was a hanging garden.
I should say something
about my wonderful wife.
Most feature's actually really cool.
Yeah.
She was very understanding
of the whole thing after her.
You have to understand that she puts so
much time and energy and love into that
garden. You've, you want
to see my wife smile,
call her name when she's in her garden
and her head will come up and she'll
smile. That she just fucking
fun. It's good for you man.
Much like hunting in a way.
There's a primal sort of a
connection that we have to gardening.
We grow our own food in my house, we grow
tomatoes, we have cucumbers, Broccoli,
and it's delicious.
We Cook it needed.
It's a some really satisfying
about growing something
and put your hands in the
dirt and it's equally satisfying
hunting your own food. Yeah. You know,
I know a lot of people don't like
that cause the hunting park cause they
connected to cruelty, but uh,
it's, it's a primal thing.
It's a primal thing.
Oh,
I should point out that even though a
lot of people have been angry at me way
more people are supporting me,
I should say that a lot of people
like to focus on the negative way more
positive comments.
I've,
that picture went up 10 minutes
ago is 3,950 likes already.
Yeah.
So it's more positive than negative,
but there's just a lot of hypocritical
bullshit out there and you got to take
the hit in order to sort of
get that subject out there.
It's one of the things about it that I,
I find a men now it's
up to 4,000 as we speak.
One of the things that I
think is important is to
take that hit is to get that
conversation going and I think a lot of
people that said the negative things,
then they,
it's a knee jerk thing.
It's because we've been shielded
from where food comes from.
We've been shielded from how do you get
meat, but you don't get meat from a seed.
Okay. You get get meat from an animal
and it has to die in order for me to,
and the seat you're sitting in and you
and your shoes, you're wearing no shit.
Right?
I got these motherfuckers at office depot.
How many cows had a die for this?
Nobody has a problem with me wearing
a murdered animal. Animal Skin.
If you got a photo of you smiling with
the new leather couch noted, give a shit.
Right? That's so true, right? No one's
smiling from your cash. You're really,
you're on cow skin. Have a steak from
the supermarket and you're smiling.
I'm cooking.
I've put up a hundred pictures
of me cooking on the grill
with a big smile on my
face.
No one cares.
You have one picture of the actual
intact animal and you can see his face.
It's like,
I have this joke about how you,
you can kill an animal
but you can't fuck it.
But what you can do is kill it and
cut it into a bite size portion,
meal size portion and jerk off with it.
You can use that to wrap it
around your Dick and jerk off.
And no one could really say
anything because we have this weird,
we have weird disconnect.
You would not going to jail for that.
Can't go to jail for jerking off with
a chicken cutlet. But if they call you,
caught you in the middle
of fucking a chicken,
most likely a cop's gonna fucking
take you down and have a talk.
At least at the very least, they're going
to go with the fuck is wrong with you.
I'm tired of my hands.
I want to call my friend right now as a
common San Francisco caught yet, dude,
fucking at this picture.
Here's
another thing that Steve Vernella and I
had a conversation about the other day
about,
about people who complain about hunting.
But every fucking restaurant except for
a tiny percentage serves me like you're,
you're dealing with murder houses
all over the country. I mean,
essentially animal murder houses
every fucking burger king,
every McDonald's, every other,
almost every regular restaurant,
Coco's fucking Red Barn, whatever
it is that you're serving food at.
Those are murdered animals. But we
have this weird disconnect. The,
this is a picture of me with duck
in the window. No one complained.
No one complained. Why? Because
I didn't kill those ducks.
That was you and I when we
were in Toronto. Ooh, yummy.
We're going to eat Chinese food. No
one gives a shit. Oh, that's great.
I love the Anthony Bourdain show.
He goes and eats it a bunch of places.
He eats murder. That's what he's
eating. He's eaten murder everywhere.
But we are shielded because we're a bunch
of fucking babies were shielded from
that.
Well, there's certainly a hypocrisy
to it. Um, one of my, uh, uh,
an old friend of mine, uh, was eating
veal ordered veal one night. And,
and I'm not a big fan of Villanova
because I've been a part of raising them.
We had a neighbor who he used to raise
the braised veal and honestly it was,
to me it was inhumane. And, uh, anyway,
uh, I said to this friend of mine, Geez,
you know, you know about
how veal is raised and how
it's handled and everything.
He took a cut out of it, put his
mouth, said this one is already dead.
So tell these guys about that. Tell
these guys about that, that time you,
uh, did that cost them slot or for that
person gave him a picture of the thing?
So, um, uh, some, some years ago,
um, we, uh, I,
I gave some relatives a half
of a beef for a present and uh,
so I delivered some of the meat already
and we are bringing the rest of it.
And they were going to have this big
meal while they had just beautiful steaks
and roasts mean they made several things,
wonderful cooks,
and they invited the
neighbors over and here's,
they bring their couple
of daughters along. And,
and on the farm we had a pen
that we always raised. This one,
we had a lot of cattle around where
we always were. We always raised,
I'm the one that was going
to be slaughtered because
in those days we weren't
doing the grass fed thing. We're
giving them corn and whatnot. And the,
the catalog had the same name was dinner.
And so I had taken a Polaroid picture
of this steer before I had it butchered
and wrote on the bottom of it dinner.
And so in presenting the meat at that
dinner that night and these neighbors were
there with a couple of young girls that
grow on was maybe 10 and the other one
12, um, you know,
we're about to begin eating and I make
the presentation and I hand him a picture
of dinner. And so the girl,
and that's all they, you know,
they didn't think anything of it,
just pass it around the table
and one girl would need it.
And last I heard she was still a
vegetarian. She couldn't do that, um,
connection or no, didn't, couldn't
believe that that's what you're doing.
On the other hand,
my,
I wanted to say something about this
whole thing with people eating meat and,
and not, you know, being a part of it and
whatnot. So I live in Madison, Wisconsin,
which is a very liberal town. And, uh,
the east side of Madison is particularly,
but there's a food co op over
there that our friend Carl,
our friend Carl Malcolm, uh, did a
learn to hunt program through. Yeah.
And it was wildly successful.
Um,
and so in Madison where I know an awful
lot of people and most of meat meat,
very few of them hunt.
But none of,
I can't think of anyone who has a
problem with me doing it. In fact,
they'll ask about it and whatnot.
So even the vegetarians and
vegans that I know are pretty,
you know, they're pretty okay
with it. My, my comment is eyes.
I don't have any objection
to what you're doing.
And I re read pollens article from the
New Yorker they posted the other day and
it was, was just a wonderful,
it was a long read. But um,
intelligence, the intelligence of plants
and how they adapt. And so wait a minute,
you know,
it's just a different Darwin vegans,
just because they don't have
a brain doesn't mean they
don't have a certain kind
of intelligence.
Not only that,
it's been proven that plants
actually can make calculations.
Cotton plants are not as simple as a rock.
You know,
we'd like to think that in eating a plant,
you're not eating anything that's alive,
but you are, you have to eat life,
life consumes life.
We just have this ability to differentiate
between the life of an animal that we
believe has emotions or we'd
think has feelings and plants.
They can get roots to grow
toward the sound. The sound
of running water. Yeah. Wow.
They'll steer in that.
There's a type of intelligence and plants
that we don't understand and that's
also bad fertile sons of bitches. A friend
of mine read that article and he goes,
man, I just never thought of
how stressful most people,
when I fire up my lawn mower
[inaudible] when you take mushrooms,
it's one of the things you experienced
is this weird connection with that fungus
and you know, obviously a fungus
is not quite the same as a plant.
In fact funguses or actually more
closely related to animals and the art of
plants,
but there's some weird thing that's going
on while you're eating a mushroom and
part of you know, the,
the psychedelic Glor.
What people believe is that
you're communicating with
is this plant by eating it.
They also believed that about Iowasca
Iowasca the common atory plant beverage
that everybody goes down to Peru and
Brazil to take and have these visionary
experiences.
They believe that you're experiencing
some sort of intelligent connection to the
spirit world through this vehicle.
This plant vehicle plants
aren't as simple as, you know,
everybody likes to think that, oh
you eat broccoli. It's so Karma free.
You know that might be the only way to
eat Karma free is to eat shit. All right.
If you want to go around eating shit,
that might be Karma for
what organisms you would
switch to eating.
What are the next step is you would
switch to eating like non terminal
productions for plants. Mila, you
need apples. You wouldn't eat,
you wouldn't eat rubella.
But that Jane's,
the Jane's like those fierce yoga
is like those, those sacks with eat.
They will never eat onions or potatoes
and things because that's the route to
life source,
the light source.
So what they do is they eat everything
that grows above the ground so you are
allowed to eat anything that
will regenerate so you can eat.
Leave leaf is actually, I had an aunt
who was fucking crazy. She's funny.
She's not my aunt anymore. They
got divorced. She's fucking crazy.
And she's a fruitarian. Oh, nice. She
probably has no blood in his body.
How should I? She on his Ip, she was so,
but she was one of those really fucking
annoying people that like you couldn't
have a ham sandwich around her.
She would just start talking shit about,
do you know how they treat those animals?
You knew that you have to murder in. Oh,
fucking Christ.
It was just this craziness.
But the bottom line is the what people
don't want to take into account.
What they want to say is, hey, you
shouldn't kill an animal and eat it. Okay.
Should we ever kill animals? No.
Okay, you should never kill animals.
What are we going to do with all
these animals? Fucking, yeah,
we can stop that from fucking,
are we going to control the population?
What are we going to do about
predators will, well, you know,
let nature control on it. Do you
know how nature controls populations?
They fucking eat them while they're
alive. All right. Coyotes. There's a,
there's a video that I found online. It's
a crazy video. Maybe you could find it,
but these two D or get locked up,
they were battling and they
were national horns together.
Then they got locked up and
while they're locked up,
a lot of times they can't get unlocked
because the horns are organic. They flex,
the antlers are organic, they flex and
move. And if you hit it the right way,
they can get connected. The point it's
really difficult to get untangled.
So while these two deer,
we're going at it and they got locked up,
coyotes ate one of them a lie.
Wow.
So one deer is like gutted and its legs
are half missing and the other deer is
like connected to him.
Fucking freaked out and these hunters
came along and disconnected these two.
That's what you're going to get if you
don't get hung up just that bad though.
Well not bad to people because
people aren't involved in that.
But I'm saying I'm not
like I don't go like,
oh we need to get rid of predators
cause there's still mean to animals.
But I feel like it's a treat to watch it.
When I watched the two deer here,
I don't know if that's
the very specific video,
but there are situations also like in
certain indigenous cultures where you
can't grow anything. Tell Eskimos
to be vegetarians. You're basically,
you have to eat the animals in parts of
the Middle East where you're not growing
anything in on the topography of the land.
You have to live off animals.
You've got to let them off the milk of
your camel in the bond to belt in Africa,
you have to basically live off.
It's very hard to grow stuff there.
You basically have to live
off of, you know, game meat,
you know, try living off of, try growing
something in the, it is the video.
The support here is connected to this
other deer that's pretty just alive.
And the hunters found the coyote
eating it. The hunters found the coyote
eating the one deer and this,
you're like, mother Fucker,
let me go and he can't get
go. I can't let go. And the,
the other deer is just like
half of his body is missing.
So they had to hold onto
them and look where they are.
Farm country starts please.
Yeah, it's Doug's house.
I owed his hands in his pockets
going, hey, what's going on dude?
If I lived in your house, man,
that, that whole area, you know,
we've talked about me buying land in
your area and I'm still really interested
in now because there's something
so fucking cool about that area,
the driftless area and there's something
so fucking cool about just your house.
We could go out of your house in
the morning, go for a walk pit,
pitch up a tent and fucking hang out
and wait for someone to come by. Yeah,
I mean it's, it's really
an amazing spot. Well
thanks. Ah, you know, I've, I feel really
lucky to be the one who gets to take
clearly that is the driftless area
for this generation. Beautiful.
That place as he looks like in
the summer song. Seriously. Yeah.
We can say we keep saying you
saying Doug's place, but dogs. Oh,
thank you Steve. I want to point out it's
Debbie. Doug's family's place in Doug's.
How long
you got or it's been
in my family 112 years.
Yeah, 112. He, yeah, he had a relative
loses sound bits on the next generation.
Went Back [inaudible] I
told you that in confidence.
[inaudible] what happened was during
the, uh, depression, my,
my great grandfather, um,
so when I say it's been in my family
112 years, there was a little,
there was a couple of months
listen,
so we don't
qualified to be a century farm
or something. But, uh, uh,
my great grandfather had a railroad
that went from Cazenovia to Laval,
which is seven miles away.
And the depression came and then there
was a flood and wiped out all the bridges.
And uh,
then he had this one.
I can tell it my dad
would be okay with this.
So one of his uncles,
I guess always had these harebrained
ideas that he could talk his father into
financing him on. So, um, he mortgaged
our farm. So our farm is not,
it's been in the family that long,
but it's not the original family farm
over where, by where we were duck hunting.
I pointed that out. Um, that's where
the, um, the homestead was anyway
in every guy in his area is Doug's,
Doug's got cousins he never even met.
They're like down the road.
Yeah.
Pop out of the woodwork when
November rolls around. Cousin. Hey,
let's go Emily.
Yeah, I think folks are on
kids know, you would say, well,
some people would say that, you know,
I wouldn't get that fucking driven.
There's a dude that ran at hunter.
There's the dude next to me. Yeah.
That ran that uh,
that,
that hunter recruitment program
out of that whole foods places
as a co op. Yeah. And uh, Carlos,
just one of those guys, you know,
he's just wonderful, uh, advocate
for the outdoors and uh, yeah,
that was the,
that was our first time,
I guess the first time that we did
together cause Durkin was there.
So there was no, that was the
second time you hunted on my farm.
Been this is the fourth time anyway.
Huh? What was I talking
about? Hunting? No, you're old
man. You're all [inaudible].
So, yeah, railroads. And so anyway,
uh, it came to a point where
we'll, we've got to have some,
something's got to give.
So he gave the farm what let the farm
go back to Northwestern mutual life is
what my dad said. And uh,
and my grandfather had,
interestingly, it didn't make sense
for him to buy it from his father.
He bought it from the insurance company,
had the paper on it.
So there was like a few month period
of time where it was in no man's land,
but no one else has owned the place
for 112 years. That's the alarm.
Is it a ministry of foreign man?
It's amazing spot. It's a beautiful,
beautiful spot. Well, there've been people
well taken care of it for a long time.
I give my father an awful lot of
credit for, you know, his, um,
vision on the whole thing
in my, my grandfather was a
really interesting guy too.
And, um, you know, they, Eh, I didn't
know my great grandfather obviously, but,
uh, but yeah, I mean it's just, I,
it's just my turn right now and I happen
to have four brothers and sisters who
are very, uh, uh, willing to, uh,
sort of let me be in charge and, and
uh, we're all partners in the thing. Um,
and my folks are still heavily
involved but are as they always say,
we control the purse strings like there.
Yeah. Like they're the house of
representatives or something.
I wish you had a picture of the standard
that we could put up on the thing there,
man. Yeah. I don't know where you
find one of the standards. Yeah.
Douglas Standard. Dot. Yeah. Don't
kill the one time killed a giant. Well,
you have pictures of that on your first
time here. Don't know where there,
Joe dog killed a giant buck
became known as the standard,
as a standard on that property. It's
a really funny story. I feel like I'm,
I feel like this is like Mary Ann
[inaudible] going to tell him. Doug,
tell him about this dog.
Tell me about that dog.
Why don't you tell him Steve Youtube to
the standards of funny story without a
picture. I got a lot of people die and
watching anyways. They're listening.
Tell the story a fair enough.
Tell us story about the standards.
Do you want me to, are you curious
about here to start? Yeah, absolutely.
What I like about the standard story is,
um,
how I went up there with the tractor
and set this whole thing on the part.
I like,
this is never gonna work because the part
I like is when you tell when you took
it down to the Oh, oh yeah, yeah.
Okay. Took it down to the guy. So, so,
so here's what happened.
I like two weeks before,
uh, this early, it was an early gun
season. It was actually during bow season.
At that time it was very controversial,
but you can earn a buck.
So this is like the end of October.
So rod is just kicking off.
And my nephew a shot a doe with the night
before and had never got into deer and,
and um, in fact he shot one earlier that
day. And, uh, I said, well, go ahead Sam,
you know, got it out. He said, well, I
didn't go. I don't know how to do it.
And they said, well, if I got that deer,
I'm gonna tag it so that I could have
the buck tag. Two weeks before this day,
my wife and I were driving down through
the farm on that road that comes down
through there in this just enormous
buckets up out of this brush and goes just
lumbering into the woods. And my wife who
doesn't get excited about deer is like,
oh my God, look at the size
of, but she got excited.
So later that day I went up with the
tractor and a brush hog, you know,
and nothing going on here.
I'm just driving through cutting the
trails on the farm and left the tractor
idling, jumped down off the tractor,
grabbed a, I had a tree stand along,
strapped it to a tree, um, got back
in the tractor while it was, you know,
just as I said, let it run the whole
time and then drove out of there.
Two weeks later,
I had this buck tag and
shoot the deer 10 minutes.
Unfortunately,
it's not one where I can tell a long
story about why can make any story line
apparently. But, um, along story
about hunting the steer and all that,
it showed up 10 minutes after I
got into standing boom shot yet.
And that's the standard. So,
and this thing is just enormous.
I mean it's just one on
your wall. Yeah. That,
that rope and it was just a
huge deer. Besides how much
did it weigh? Let's think.
I Dunno, I go to 65 or, or
something like that, maybe to 70.
And I'm,
well the thing is like,
it's like, uh, it, you know,
it had to be as quick as did here. You
get into like how many inches of antler.
So it was a hunter.
It was almost a 200 inch deer in the
Antler, but it was an enormous body dear,
besides, so, um, never shot
anything like that before.
So I call this tax the dermis and said,
so I want to bring this deer in.
And he said, well, how big
is it? And I said, well,
I have size 13 shoes and I can put
both of my shoes between the antlers.
Oh, well you didn't want to get that
in here real soon. And you know,
so the skin doesn't, the high doesn't
slip and all this stuff. So, um,
my dad's got this little
Chevy F's 10 pickup.
We dropped the thing in the back so it
looks like an elk in the back of this
little tiny pickup.
And we drive it to the taxi type.
And by the time we get
to the texts and stuff,
there are two or three vehicles behind
us cause they want to see where it's
going. We pull into the place
and I walk up and there's this,
this texted them shop where
they also registered dear.
You guys had the experience with
places where they registered dear.
It's a madhouse.
And uh,
so we pull in there and I walk up
to the guy and said, oh, by the way,
I'm the guy who, who called and you've
got the buck with. They said, oh,
can I see it?
And they've got trucks are backed in there
and they're unloading Dyrand skin and
amount and doing all this stuff.
And my little dad's a little s tennis
sitting down at the bottom of the hill and
he walks down there and he goes,
all right,
everybody get all these
vehicles out of the way.
We're back in this one
up in here right now.
So we back it up there and they'd
get it out of the thing and uh,
out of the back and they, they do a
quick skin of it till they get it to the,
to the head. And so I, and he's got a guy
who all he does is surgically removed,
you know,
do the Cape and whatnot.
We go in there and guys start
chucking $5 bills into a,
or $10 bills into a hat and
start writing numbers down.
So they're guessing as to how
many inches of horn there is.
So every big deer that comes in, that's
what they were doing. But it was just a,
the whole scene was how many inches
was, it was 192. That's a big,
the one that you got was like 1218
what is that right
there? That mule deer.
How big is that? Oh Shit.
110 that's how big fucking
animal you had then. But it is,
it's just like something happens kind
of magically when they get up into that.
They just started, I mean
genetics, genetics, food.
There's a big one right there.
That's a mule deer though,
isn't it?
It's not even type in 200 inch whitetail.
Well,
I've seen some of them they have that
looks like they have trees grown out of
their heads.
Yeah.
Type in 202 whites and you'll probably
hit like 220 now Alberta is the place
where I came here and has the big ones.
They got big bodied.
You're in for a long time. They
were the reigning. There was like,
there was a place to go if you
wanted to shoot a huge racked.
I mean just besides body, you get the
body to think. We talked about that.
Bergman's principal bought why animals
in the north are big. What the fuck?
That's crazy. That's big.
That's big. That's insane.
So it's very elk like,
uh,
for Awhile Alberta was the place to go
if you wanted to kill it and they still
got plenty of who's deer. But then all
this stuff started happening and Illinois,
Ohio, Wisconsin, Iowa, and they're
just killing fricking tankers now. Wow.
Like tech for awhile. Like
Texas was the man. There you go.
That's ridiculous food plots.
Right? Soybeans make. So for awhile,
like Alberta was the man in Texas was
the man right now the Midwest is just
crank and huge.
If big huge antlered white till all
your thing and you want to shoot one.
I didn't ask you that.
You want to shoot one in the wild and not
like shooting one that some guy raised
on, reared on offense, reared
off his fricking study animal.
Well I watched this one show where it
was about a deer farm and they were
showing all these d or that they had
genetically raised and these deer farm and
it's ridiculous. I mean they, they,
they have trees growing out of their
head and there are only two years old,
two year old deer and the got fucking
these weird crazy antlers you can't trust.
You can't trust white tails.
If I walk into dude's house and I
walk into a guy's house and he's like,
check out that Greg Whitetail,
I'm like, you know, I,
I can't even start even kind of pretending
to be impressed until I knew the
backstory. I, as far as I know,
you shot it up behind a fence.
You walk into guys' place,
he's got a big tank or like big horn.
He's probably got something.
If he's got a big tank or mule deer,
there's a group. Very good chance he's
really got something, a big tanker elk.
I'm like, God, I'm going to have
to know what was going on. So elk,
you were saying this before the podcast.
There are elk that are behind fence.
Oh Shit. Yeah. Tons of man. Where tons
of lots of, I mean, you could probably,
there's probably, there's more
states that do it, but no,
I should say it was more that
do it then don't, but like,
I'll rattle off a bunch
to do Texas and it'll,
Pennsylvania has got a bunch
of high offense places.
Missouri's got high fence places.
Idaho is high fence places for out.
There's something about an elk in a
high fence that kind of offends me.
You get to do three, 4,000 bucks. I mean,
they'll drive you out and
you pick the one you won out.
I've seen ads we say
like, it'd be like, um,
someone needs to hunt this elk now.
$3,000. Isn't that a good picture?
The other day? Something about an elk
that's a mythical sort of a mystical,
majestic creature. I hate, I hate
to see them. I hate to see him.
I'd argue the same thing
about a whitetail deer.
I just can't imagine going
behind, uh, you know,
going into a fence and she's one of
those places in Texas. Well, I mean,
they haven't been Wisconsin too.
There's a place called gonna.
I don't want it went to a place in Texas.
It's 10,000 acres.
Is that okay?
Yeah, I know you get into
weird, you get into the,
you get into a thing where it's become,
I mean,
there was a big thing you
see Hans advertise on, on
a 300 acre chunk of ground.
It has no fence on it or I'm
sorry, no tree on it. Right.
And you get a nice things where someone
might be doing this amazing wildlife
management, you know, and doing
a really good management job.
And for whatever reason,
it could be any number issues.
They for their own management
purposes, fence, a gigantic track,
Landon and you get into, so is that
legit or not? And it's kind of like,
who's that guy that said,
I only know I know porn when I see it.
I know I can't define pour, but show
me a picture on tape. It's porn or out.
But that was the supreme court justice
who said, I don't know how to define it,
but I know when I see it.
So it's insanity rules. But,
but what I'm saying is
that what if you're,
there's something about being
out in the middle of nowhere,
like the Missouri breaks. That
is, that feels more challenging.
Yeah. It's a luxury though too, because
a lot of people don't have people.
Like when I was growing up, man, it was B,
we own the farthest we'd
hunt from our house.
We typically have between two
and eight miles from our house.
We were going on a big ass trip,
a big ass trip to drive 40 miles up
and hunt this place called peacock in,
uh, in Lake County. I didn't
grow up thinking, I mean,
we grew up hunting what we had
around us. Man. I, you know,
now I lose sight of it now because
I have, you know, I have such a,
like a kind of fell into such a fantastic
occupation where now I'm like, Oh yeah,
you know, we'll go here and go there for
all these wild hunts and like, you know,
the real way to hunt is this and
that and the Alaska in mountains.
You're talking about Alpine hunting,
like when you're on the swallows. Yeah.
When you're up in the
mountains and and you're,
you're having it really literally bring
everything with you going up and down a
mountain.
That feels a lot more challenge.
Yeah,
you get into a ton of physical challenges,
but it is a luxury in most of the people.
I mean more hours are logged
deer hunt in the near cut,
logged hunt whitetail deer
ears and in your kind of
the number one killed thing
is what doves are co doves.
I think number one is killing me. That's
a real issue with people, man. That doves,
they go crazy.
It's the symbol of,
in Michigan you can dumps piece.
Camper mentioned we used to,
we used to. We used to when we were
kids, we hunted them on the sly.
You guys shouldn't cut off branches
either because them and adults together
equal piece. He said good heating
or tubs that tastes very good. Dark,
flush, dark flavor,
flavor. Fast is the best.
Don't say it. Don't look
pheasant, but I mean look at us.
Here's why tops, but pigeons are okay.
Not, Doug's apparently chickens, chickens,
pigeons and dogs have
a lot in common. But a dove
is better morning doves
business. All right. This dark
liver colored. Yeah. So I'm the exact
opposite of Steve though. I mean, I've,
I've hunted to other places
than our area in my entire life.
I'm 55 years old. I hunted
the boundary waters, uh,
deer hunted up there four or five years
ago and last spring and went down and
hunted, uh, Twinkies.
What's the boundary waters?
Boundary waters in northern Minnesota.
It's the boundary between Wisconsin
and Minnesota. It's very wild.
No, it isn't. It thought isn't
the boundary waters. It's
Canada minutes. I'm sorry.
Canada, Minnesota. Yeah. I don't even
need to look that up. My New Internet.
Yeah. So, um, but so most
of my hunting, you know,
and I've been doing it since I was
12, so it's a lot of years, um,
has been done on that farmer in
that area and, and really not,
you know, elsewhere. I guess I
hunted a little bit when I was in,
when I lived in New Hampshire for a few
years too. But, um, you know, sort of the,
um, the optic opposite
experiences of, of Steve. Um,
but nonetheless it challenging. Yeah.
I don't disagree with you at all.
Whitetail deer hunting's really
accessible. It's becoming
because of guys like me I suppose,
um,
a little less accessible because I don't
necessarily just when I was a kid you
could pretty much go hunting anywhere.
I mean we just get in the
car on a Saturday morning
and just go and go into that
woods and you know, not deer
hunting something. But when
I was a kid, deer hunting,
you had to put four guys together in like
August or September, fill out a form,
send it into the DNR to
get a tag to shoot a doe.
So that's the whole idea. So
one dough for four, four guys,
everybody else had a buck tag. So, and
that was the idea was that there was the,
to bring the population up,
well now it's exactly the opposite
where we're encouraging, I mean,
they have earn a buck rules that kind
of got shot down, but earn a buck is,
is in place that Steve
asked me the other day,
well how many deer could you
shoot on your tag? And I was like,
there's no limit that
I'm just trying to calculate the cost,
the hunting during Wisconsin,
it's like what you buy a tag for 18 bucks.
It's good for in your area.
Yeah. In our area. Um, you
get a buck tag, a doe tag,
a second doe tag,
and then every time you go in they'll
give you another paper tag. That's
interesting. That's off a
permit. The cost of what?
Well,
it was $24.
$24. Yeah. That's crazy. That's a good way
to get meat for cheap if you, yeah, man,
it's a, it's like if you're, if you're
hunting local and it's economical
and when I was, yeah, yeah. And when I was
a kid, if, if a deer got hit on the road,
people stopped and picked it
up and put it in the back.
But now it's like now because of the snow,
we've had a big melt recently.
You see the big drifts or the snow piles
along the edge of the road and here's
deer carcasses turned it on.
You can't eat them.
You can't pick them up too late now.
But it depends on the states,
the Galtee. But you know
like now, now in Montana you
can, you can now it was illegal.
Now you can pick up certain species.
You can, you can salvage them.
You've got to let the state know.
We used to just have to call,
you said call nine one one they'd give
you a permit for deer were coming back
one time. Mile man hit a
deer with his bow. Okay.
We all go out to blood trail of
deer blood trail dear till one,
two in the morning. Never followed
the deer. Never recovered a deer.
I can't remember where he hit it. Probably
hit it in the paunch or something.
Never found it coming back.
He's got me, my brothers now.
Little little like I was so little
that me and my other brother,
we got left behind and he left us to sleep
in the woods and our land and ran out
of gas.
So I light was out and we fell
asleep and so he couldn't find us.
And they're running around and goes,
Dave Dad,
cause you'd have to get close enough to
yell and wake us up. Two in the morning,
we're coming home finally driving
a jeep AMC eagle or dry GF,
AMC Cherokee. And by him hit this deer.
So it's, you know, everyone's tired.
I'm sleeping up front. My brother was
in the back seat, mailman gets out,
grabs his deer and throws the on bits
and back of the jeep Cherokee on a tarp,
sticks in Arrow in it. Nope.
Start on down the road.
And all of sudden my brother was in
the back flipping out like freaking.
And we turned around that
somebody just standing up,
oh no.
Slams on the brakes, gets out in the
halls head, you're out of the bat,
cause its throat weights come and stills
it back in there on a tarp and continue
on our way home.
That was a hard man. Oh my God. For
Life. You guys sleep in the woods.
You fucking pussy. Here's a lantern with
three ounces of fluid in it right now.
Go to sleep. I came back, I gave the kid
a compass, whatever. No, he was, he was,
um, he was, uh, he was a
hard guy, man. Yeah, I guess,
yeah, I guess that sounds
like a hard guy at the time.
Like it up until,
you know,
it's funny cause it's like there's this,
uh, there's a, there's like this music,
I don't even want to name her name,
but she's got the song like I'm not
angry anymore. Like my dad's been dead.
Like my dad died in
2002, 2003. I'm just now,
I just turned 40, a couple,
like a week or two ago.
I'm just now getting where I'm not so
angry at him and I'm starting to go like a
lot of what he did made sense
and love it has to do with,
I have a three year old now. Oh yeah.
And now I'm like, you know what?
Maybe he wasn't like, so you
know, it just looked like, look,
I look at it through that angle now having
a little kid and I see like you want
that person to be just like able to
fend for themselves and know and to be
capable and know how to fix stuff and
know how to take situations in their own
hands and know not to complain about
stuff. You know what I mean? Well,
you came out pretty good. I mean, yeah,
but most people disregard everything
they learned from their parents.
Even if they turned out really good.
Like you could have a whole slew of
siblings all be turned out great.
And in every one of them will be like,
do the opposite of what their parents did.
What do you think you were so angry
about? I mean, what was the thing?
I don't wanna get you to me in a hard
ass. Yeah, Megan's work all the time.
All the time.
These pads,
he used to have a longer one and he
start making chores and he wouldn't like
suck. He would just keep going until
he had two columns down to the bottom.
My Dad would do that but then you get on
your first day of summer break and he'd
be like,
you know,
can you believe this shit that's going
to take you through August two that
somebody didn't have any staying power
like he was. He would write up list. I,
I crashed my car,
this car and it cost him like I don't
know how much it's going to cost some
Vegas. You're working for this,
you're working for this boy.
I'll tell you that much right now.
Hope you hope you think,
I know you had plans for the summer
cause cause you can kiss those plans,
go back cause you're going to be
working or not. And he was so mad at me.
Meanwhile I knew he
wrote this long Lizzie.
I knew he just kind of forgot about it.
It just means it never had any staying
power. He'd get busy and I'd be like, see,
you later dropped this list and it
wasn't I supposed to mow the lawn. Sorry,
I've got a trick niece.
No, you probably know dad.
I'm going to grow up and be a comedian
to my mother. My mother used to,
my mother used to change my grades.
I would get my report card and
it sucked and I knew my father,
my father, I need to change
it for you. Oh my God.
I couldn't go to my dad with a d in
math and I was just, I mean, you know,
you don't think I listened now can you
imagine you fucking in fucking high
school. Holy Shit. Was I a mess?
What did your parents think when you
said you wanted to be a comedian?
My father grew up really poor, so when
I told him I wanted to be an actor,
not even a comedian, an actor
that we just told them first. Yup.
I was 2122 I remember,
I remember he looked at me and his face,
I remember his face,
the worry and the regret and the
dread, but you know what? He's like,
I should've never even [inaudible]
a drone in when he was little,
he was so, he was so to see, right.
He was so depressed because he,
he just wanted me to be, you know,
he just want to be, he loved
me. He's wanting to be safe.
So he just looked at me and he
goes like this. He goes, well,
why are you asking me if I'll support you?
I mean,
you want some money for your rent?
I go, I go, no. He goes, well,
you're going to need it because you're
not paying your way around with acting,
so you're good. We have
to talk brass tacks. You,
you can't live in New York
without my help. And I never
forgot that about him. He,
he, he, he kind of, he just, you know,
he said, oh, well he's a dreamer.
Here goes nothing.
But then when I got my first job,
when I got mad TV and I called him,
it was the greatest thing in the world.
He goes, what are you doing in la? And
I go, ah, I'm on a TV show. And he goes,
what do you mean when I go,
I'm going to be on a TV show every week
and he got commercial, I don't know,
commercial. I'm going
to be on a TV show, use.
I can turn the channel on and you'll
be on the show. I go, that's right.
And he goes like this. There was
a pause and he goes, Oh my God,
I've got to call your mother.
And he hung up.
And then my mother called and my cousins
call, everybody called and he just,
he didn't know how to even deal
with the emotion of it cause I was,
I was ultimately the first time you don't,
but, but forget all that bullshit. What,
what ended up bringing us really close,
because we didn't really get
along that well, was how,
how well I kept my head up during
the fact that I wasn't working.
I spent a lot of time and you know,
for years not working as an act,
you didn't say quit. I never quit, man.
And I never got down. I never got down.
I would just go, well here goes
another one. I just never fucking game.
I don't give him wait way.
We will.
You didn't spend that much time not
working because what? I'm to you,
when I met you, you were like 26
yeah. And you were working. Yeah,
but I went a long time without the fuck.
I'm saying,
I mean TV show from college to
not working. What does that work?
A little bit probably doesn't mean
you're making about being an actor,
like all the years of not getting jobs.
And about how long is that?
If you were 26 well, from the age
of when you get out of college,
how old were you? 21 so you five years?
No, I worked at a bank for two years.
And so five years. Five years from school?
No, I'm talking about, it's not like,
it's probably not like a
[inaudible] magazine Articles,
magazine articles 2000 but it was, it took
me five years to get it. I can be like,
yes, I'm a publishing writer.
I'm a writer. Writer. Right,
but he was on mountain talking about
a match after that work a lot like
[inaudible] I'm doing gay comedy, whatever
dirt. No, I was insisting on doing,
I'm doing acting. Joe would be
like, Dude, stop with the act.
I'd be an acting class. We get in
these huge arguments. He'd be like,
just do stand up just to stand
up with this acting step.
I would freak out and pilot
season. I'd call him up. I
didn't get a job. This pile.
Why wouldn't you want to be
autonomous when you could be?
I just didn't understand the greatest.
Like when I was on news radio, my,
the producer actually said to me, he
goes, why are you still doing standup?
You're an actor now. I was
like, oh, really? Like, oh,
I get to get the fuck away from you
right now before. This is contagious
to be a stand up for stand up.
The most beautiful thing about standup
is you've got everything with you. You,
you, you're, you carry your
equipment. You are who you are.
You go to a club and you
don't need anything to turn
on the microphone and we'll
do this. Turn the lights off, turn
on the microphone. We're good.
The last thing you want is to stand up
is to have to check in with a bunch of
other people. If you got to do
what you have to do as a standup,
what you have to do as an act or like
go to producers and writers and the
network, get everything approved.
It's a fucking disaster.
Which is one of the reasons why it's so
hard to get a good show on television.
That perfect storm of good writing and
good acting and all that stuff coming
together.
It's incredibly difficult to
play practically impossible
and let's be honest,
we have the greatest job in
the world. Am I right? Well,
it's also the most fun to me when I'm
a con, when I'm an audience member,
I would way rather go see
Brian Cowen do stand up.
Then I'll go see you in a movie
and then go see you in a movie.
And you can see Brian Cowen to stand up
in San Francisco this weekend, Thursday,
Friday, Saturday at the punchline. Yes.
See you and you're very
funny doing stand up,
but you know the odds of you getting a
role that represents you the same way it
does your, your standup.
It's not only that, like you,
when you go to see a good
comic, the laughs that you
have in an hour and a half,
like you get out of there, your fucking
stomach hurts. Yeah. You know, you're,
you were howling laughing when we went
to see you. I remember I told you,
my wife said,
might like my arms and my face hurts.
If you go from holding that like
big smiley thing for whatever,
15 minutes, Joe Rogan or you see
bill burr, you see these guys,
let me tell you something. You take the
funniest movie in the world. The hangover,
any movie, I don't care what it is. They,
there was no way that that audience is
going to laugh as much at the hangovers
last per minute. It's not
gonna happen, you know,
and there's a real problem with the
way it's expressed on television too.
And I'm having an issue with that now. Um,
my new special bar, the word comes out,
uh,
this,
this Friday night on this Friday
night on comedy central. They're,
they're airing my, not my latest.
I know that my last special, yes.
Live from the Tabernacle.
Uh,
the special that I did I guess was about
a year and a half ago and now I'm doing
a new one. I'm going to film a new
one in June because I this special,
if you see this special,
there's none of this is on my
new comedy that I'm doing now.
So over the last like year and a half,
I've been putting together my new hour.
It's done now and I'm probably going
to film that most likely in Denver,
most likely in June.
We're at piecing it together.
I want to do it at the comedy
works cause I love that cloud.
If I can do it there, I'll do
it there. If not, I'll do it.
I want to do it at a club.
I'm trying to figure out
how to represent con.
Like when you see a comedy
show on television, I'm sorry,
it's just not as good as seeing it live.
There's something he miss.
There's something about the person's
saying that shit right in front of you.
That's just way better than someone
saying that shit on a video.
It's like watching the concert.
It's like watching a concert video.
There's nothing more painful than
watching the concert video. True.
When I saw you recently in Chicago,
one of the neat things is, you know,
sitting there with a friend but,
but the people around you,
like what struck somebody else says
just like gut wrenching, you know,
busting funny. Um,
yeah, that's funny. But,
but then the thing that would get me
would be the other people are kind of
chuckling and I'm just roaring,
you know?
And it's like that shared
experience I think as a part of it.
I think it is too.
There's something about going and and I,
and I think the shade experience somewhat
gets diminished when there's like more
than 3000 people. I've had great times
like when we did a Toronto, what we do.
Would you to Denver with me
when it came out as me? Yes.
Oh Great.
[inaudible] I had them introduce of
Calvin goes out there and they're all
looking at me like, wow, pretty cool.
Let's get to get that reception.
I felt like the Messiah and then I
could see the front row going on.
Joe Looks, he looks thinner. I
Scott Eight [inaudible] tall,
gained three inches, lost 50 pounds.
Joe Rogan light. There it is. Oh yes.
This is actually the video.
Just come walking out.
How high were we then?
We thought this was a good idea
to in Toronto is amazing. Yeah. 3000
people. Well this was, this was Denver.
I wasn't a Denver.
This is several thousand haven.
Well you hear the like, well what time
you fucking freaks. That's what Joe says.
What's that you fucking phrase?
No,
what the fuck dude?
One of the best things about seeing,
like you talk about that experience
of being an audience. When I,
when I saw you recently in New York,
it was like you brought up the,
you kind of launched into the duck
dynasty thing. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's some dudes in the audience.
I could see a lot of guys in the audience.
They started getting real excited because
they're like awesome because now he's
going to start bashing the queers.
Like now we can talk really
bad about gay people.
Don't charge something like come on,
talk bad about queers. I can't wait.
And then Joel like solely turns it on
its head and it's most vicious way and
like the palpability these
dudes disappointment that
it wasn't going to be that.
We were talking about like how much
we hate gay people and they of,
they're kind of like, yeah,
bring it, bring it in in a,
in a does like just shot him down in the
worst way and they're kind of getting
this little like Yoda,
I think this pissy little mood and this
whole thing's playing out right in front
me. Like, no one would ever know to send
you your wife and these guys get like,
aw man,
I thought I was gonna be more fun
than [inaudible] gets crushed.
Well what it is is that you know,
they,
they think that you're going to like
support his freedom of speech. You know,
cause that's like the big argument
that you see on, on Facebook.
What about freedom of speech?
What about his,
his Christian beliefs about supporting
his Christian beliefs? You know,
my point on all that has always been
why would you care what gay people are
doing? Like what's going on at you care
about gay people. And if it's the Bible,
if you're, it's, you're really
fucking cherry picking. If
you go on after the game,
like your Cherry,
Cherry Creek,
you should go after people that were two
different types of cloth because that
shit's in there too.
Yeah.
But the whole premise of the show is like,
did they made a boatload of money?
But isn't there a line in the Bible
like a rich man has as much chance of
getting into heaven as a camel
passing through the eye of a needle?
That's what Jesus said.
Yes,
that's exactly what you're more worried
about whether reality TV stars get
to go to heaven.
Well,
you're a liar if you're doing that show
and you're not telling people that it's
scripted,
you're a liar.
So that that is an issue and that's a
real issue with those reality shows.
They are not reality.
Those shows are fucking scripted.
So most often you have to
sign a nondisclosure. If
you work for duck dynasty,
she worked for a lot of those shows.
If you're a camera man,
if you're a sound guy,
you have to sign a nondisclosure so
that you can't go out and tell everybody
that it's all bullshit.
Yeah. That, that's, that's like one of
the most basic things I get is this,
like how it comes that when
you look at what's going
on in the world, the bad things are
happening, the world, starvation,
abuse, the children, all these
things go on in the world.
And you and you hone in on like what's
going on in some guy's private life,
whether or not there's like
point, by the way, all the problems that
really are affecting people, you, you,
you're,
the problem in this world really is
homosexual two dudes having brunch with
disposable income Sunday,
who gives a fuck?
It's, it's very weird.
We're very weird about that.
We're very weird about what we decide
to get upset about and what we don't
decide to get upset about it.
It's, it's a strange thing.
And what we should be upset about.
We're not. And on a show like that,
well you should be upset about it as
a fact. They're fucking faking it.
That's not a drama. It's
not like watching, you know,
fill in the blank fucking game of
Thrones where you know, it's scripted.
This is a show. They're pretending
this is their real life and it's not.
One of the things that I really appreciate
about your show is that it's 100%
legit above board all the way.
If you don't get an animal,
you show the whole fucking show
and you've had several shows.
Well you don't get an animal.
And one of them that I really respected
man was that episode this year where you
had that bear in your site and you just
decided not to shoot it and you had,
this is a very unique episode because
you're fucking bear hunting and you are a
hunter and you've killed,
God knows how many animals in your life
and you had your cross hairs on his bare
and it was a done deal. And
he said, I'm not feeling it.
I don't want to shoot this animal.
And just weird
for me. No, I say that. But then I went
shot one shot burned out long after that.
But, but no at that.
Yeah, that happens to me.
But you apologized after
you shot that bear,
which I thought was weird too because you
wounded it and then you had a shoot it
a second time and you said
you were sorry for hurting it.
Yeah. But like, yeah, I
feel, I don't know man bears.
I love to hunt bears and I like to look
at barriers and sometimes I confuse
which of those I like. It's confusing
to me, which I like more, you know,
why is that? I feel, um,
kind of an f I feel like an
affinity to bears in a way.
I just kind of is that someone,
somebody,
their favorite foods are
so favorites of mine too.
Like I'll watch bears go eat blueberries.
It's like I love eating blueberries
at that place. I got in Alaska,
the bears all blue mussels and boom,
muscles are like one of my favorite
things in the world. And so I was like,
you look at it bear, it's
like, man, we're kind of,
I always feel like we like the
exact same foods, you know?
And another thing about bears,
um,
is I feel that bears kind of wake
up a little different every day.
You know, they, they're, they're,
they, they, they experiment, you know,
they're processing things and
experimenting with things. And, um,
and so it's a,
it's a potent animal for me.
And I think that if you look at just
the history of hunting in the history of
hunters as represented through art,
did they leave behind an oral tradition
they leave behind is not a new concept
that a homeowner would develop
an affinity to certain animals.
You know, oftentimes people respected
the animals that they hunted the most.
You look at the, the, the, the race
relationship plains tribes to Buffalo,
Bison, it was like an object
of worship, very sacred object.
You have a very conflicted,
complicated relationship with the animal
and Johan it and kill it. So I'm not,
I don't even need to feel funny about the
way I feel towards some of the animals
I hunt because it's like,
it's just something that has obviously
happened to hunters for long, long time.
Um, and, and as a hunter you
kind of develop your own system.
Like we never use the word taboo
when we're talking about ourselves.
We always use tab. We, when we're looking
at other cultures and be like, oh,
those crazy people, they won't eat that
because they have a taboo. Meanwhile,
like we don't eat dogs, you
know, we have a taboo system,
we have a taboo system that
governs the things we do. And I,
through hunting and through
observations of animals and there's,
I've developed a set of things that I
will and will not do and there's animals
that to me are really special,
you know,
not that I dislike other ones,
but just the bare to me is special.
I'll go bear hunting this June and I'm,
I'm thinking about it.
It's just something that,
you know,
I look at a bear and I respect
it as a renewable resource.
Something that if managed properly
I can kill the bear, have it's hide,
render its fat down and make my own lard
with it. Eat all the meat. I like that.
But I also something about him,
he really likes the individual bear too.
And just to observe them and, and now
and then just to let one walk. Yeah.
You said something really interesting
to me just now about the fact that they
wake up differently every day and
that that's something getting,
cause what you're saying is that
they kind of learn as they get older.
I feel that's the case. That process.
Whereas a deer, you don't feel that way.
I don't a failure,
well it's two or it's one or it's five.
I mean they learn but
it's not the same thing.
I have a hard time thinking of whites.
I have a hard time
thinking of whitetail deer.
Most things I have a hard
time thinking of as as um,
as individuals [inaudible]
bear like really?
Especially after I killed that bear I
was talking about was 17 and I got that
back and they, the tooth, I think it's
called a dentist that they do. Yeah,
they cut a cross section on that tooth.
They got back and thought 17 man.
Cause at the time I was mad. I was
in my early twenties man. Awesome.
My early toys.
I'm like that's some bitch.
Then the rock for 17 that's what Tesla
with that 17 year old bear tastes like.
I kept some rolls off the back legs and
I kept the loins and things fine man.
But like I said, I ground a lot of it, but
I did keep some rolls off it. We ate it,
we sloppy Joe, we did everything. And then
the loins, we just grill. And how was it?
The grilled lines,
they'll still a good barrier.
You have to make it medium right with a
bear because plus with that bear I knew,
I knew he was head trichinosis
so it was good. You know,
I can't even like, it was so long ago
now I, I mean I remember it being good.
Everybody being really surprised
by I was good. But I'll handle bear
meat in different ways.
You know,
I don't just like cut a chunk of
bear meat and throw it on the grill.
Like I do a lot of,
you know,
you might want to tenderize it or I'll
do marinades on and I'll smoke it.
Like I bring more effort to bear
meat than I would to like that,
that fine tastes and driftless area
Wisconsin Whitetail, we were eating,
which is basically warmed up.
You know,
I mean you're just like
putting a little bit, yeah,
well for the teeny bit of heat. Do
you do that with, with, with, with,
with everything,
we've got a lot of emails and comments
from people about the duck and there was
how good was the duck really? And
I'm just like, oh, it was incredible.
What do you mean? Yeah, people are just
like, well, you know, ducks. I was like,
are you talking about mallards and
Windex? I mean, cause you know,
you're talking about diving ducks. That's
a whole nother thing. But you know,
mailers or heard that screw
a mailer it up. I think
Joe showing some footage of rendering.
Yeah.
That's rendering bear fat down in oil.
And that's a bear that had been eaten.
Blueberries. Right. Those and those
are, uh, fall bears the fall. They,
they're fattening up.
There's nothing bad. I mean,
there really is nothing better than that.
Then those bears that you would
get him in late September, October,
and you're up there eating blueberries.
They'd been eating blueberries for
months. Oh my God, they're good. I mean,
they're just good. We've got to make
that happen. Listen, Brian Cowen,
we've got to go on more hunting trips.
I know I'm not shooting a bear,
but I'll go on home. I want you
to bear now. I want you to bear,
but I'll definitely shoot a deer or
an elk or anything. I'm going to you,
you'll see them in this fall for
sure. When we go moose hunting. Yeah.
I want to come. Can you come? There's
enough room. No, figure it out.
We'll figure it out.
Oh,
that sounds like there's [inaudible].
No, it's a boat. Dot. Say it. If you,
if you, if you are honestly like, dude,
I want to go so bad. Well, let's see.
I really think that the public needs to
know how fucking good your show is and I
think that,
I think we're,
we're doing our best to expose it on
this show and to expose it online and let
people know. And I, and I know
that your ratings are growing,
but I can't help feel like
you're under utilized on,
I love the sportsman channel. I watch it,
don't get me wrong, but they just large.
But channel gives us, gives us the
ability to make the show. Absolutely.
There's a lot.
You can't just go and do the stuff we do
and show the stuff we show on a regular
network. You can't, they wouldn't
let you know because they have,
they have it in their head. He can't gut
animals and all they have in their head.
There's a set of things that the
American public will tolerate and won't
tolerate.
And we had the ability to do.
We have absolute creative freedom to
show the things that I'm interested in
talking about.
But do you feel that that's changing?
Like when you watch these shows, like
these Alaska, the last frontier, yeah.
It shows, they're showing a lot of hunting
and a lot of stuff. Gutting animals,
a lot of skinning animals. They show an
animals hanging up in Barnes and shed.
Then they're showing the raw real
deal and they're doing onto the,
there's something that they feel like
is more romanticized about subsistence
living. Well. Yeah, but that's, but they,
there's a fabricated thing there where
they're always trying to like make up
this idea that this person's
gonna die if he doesn't do this,
which is just horse shit.
Well the most fabricated thing was when
they were fucking fly fishing and this,
they're like,
oh shit,
a bear's coming and then you see the bear
eating a fish and the fish is fucking
filleted. Like they baited that. Yeah.
You get a lot of trouble for that man.
That that fish was totally filleted clean.
Filets missing from the sides.
Like absolutely cut the bears eating.
And I'm like, you didn't fucking do that.
The bear did not do that. That
was a knife. Goddamn fillet knife.
A straight clean line from the
gills back. So yeah, we don't need,
we don't need it then.
We don't need to.
It can be the drama that you're living
a lifestyle out of choice and not just
some guy act like we've got a
whole damn film crew out here.
We're flying back and forth with batteries
and broken cameras and lenses every
damn day and we're going to pretend like
this guy out here is going to perish
you. What do you need to come up with
like cockamamie justification's I live a
lifestyle that I want to live and I have
very concrete resolute reasons why I
live that way.
Well,
what they're missing is the entertainment
value because a lot of those people
are fucking boring. That's where Collin
and I come in. So comedians and hunting,
that's it. You've got your content, your
fucking shell man. I'm telling you there,
it should be an hour long cause there
was so much great shit extended footage
that you guys have released.
Just this shit of a Brian singing while
we're pigeon hunting and trying to get
the Tony two minutes, man, 22 minutes.
Shit on the stick thing. I was laughing,
I was crying, I was so, I don't
remember even saying that stuff.
But then when you were you, when you
laugh at me, that's what I start laughing.
I'm like your laughter.
So ridiculous.
We're sitting there and literally having
a conversation and then I edit it with,
I have a lot of shit stolen.
Well that's the video that they shit
on the stick to the hundred mile.
The the hundred mile an hour
shit. Yeah. That's, by the way,
that shit on the stick video got over
a hundred thousand views already.
150 [inaudible]. That's our
best. It's this meat eaters.
It's mediators. Best Vision. I'm assuming
I was doing it. That's what happened.
I was doing standup in New York and
somebody goes, tell the shit story,
tell us a shit story. And I, I didn't
know what he was talking about though.
Talking about the one where I was hiking.
Remember that story I told about hiking?
I had to shit with that girl and,
and and, and I thought that's the thing. I
go, I don't have time. I'm doing my hack.
But he was talking about fucking bat.
That's crazy.
What did you say to have a look at like
about what the Shit was? Well of course.
You know what? I'm trying to
interject some education to the,
like we had talked to her. Yeah,
no kidding. So it was black,
not an OT,
which is a,
but I call my shit at black
knots call I call anyway guys.
Like yeah, that's what I'm
saying. Call my asshole.
That balloon now slicks Black Cherry,
which is what that plan was in.
There it goes again. Black Cherry.
I like to see chair. So it's, yeah,
it's three days old is 340,000
hits so far. I can play this one.
Yeah.
That was so fun too.
And that was the day when
we didn't see a single deer.
We went up in the afternoon.
Yeah.
Is that not that wind up on that stack
probably got like me decide I'm going to
actually see each other stick before.
It's a common expression,
but up until now I thought it was a myth.
It also might be something
called black done.
If we could get Brian to
break the branch off it,
crush it up and put it in his mouth.
He just needs to smell it for attention.
Well, you can see there. Let's let
people see the rest of the video online.
But we were fucking howling laughing.
There was many of those instances,
the talk and the monkey thing.
Although,
how about the where we're all sitting
around and uh, was he your brother's son?
That was their 17 year old kid. And we
start telling him fuck stories. Oh my God,
this kid's eyes light up like
plates. Joe was just saying, Joe,
John Joseph to the dad's guide,
the Kids Dad,
the kid's dad kind of looked
a little bit like, oh,
it was my brother David and Joe's
like, he's got the Internet, man.
There's no way we're going to tell him.
Oh no punches. Even I was, I was like,
oh Jesus, you want to know a little bit?
You didn't pull any punches either, pal.
You went with me on it. I guess you're
right. The kid was great pressure though.
And he ended up right
here that killed a rally.
Nice buck from the stem that you guys
were sitting in right by that white oak
tree that I said. One that's going
to walk by. I believe it. He's, yeah,
he's a good kid. Too. Fun.
Hilarious. Yeah. Good, good checks.
That whole area's sauce.
You're so lucky man.
It's such a beautiful area to go hunting
in the fact that you're there, you know,
for how long has hunting season from
archery to, to write archery started
September 15th. And then,
um, in our area there's some,
there's a little bit of time in
December where you can't hunt, but um,
it's pretty much until the weekend
after New Year's Day. That's crazy.
Then two years ago when we
did the first episode, um,
they've,
I think they've stopped this now,
but you get land owner tags cause again,
we're trying to reduce the herd.
And so when Steve called me about
that, he said, what do you think we do?
That rabbit hunting thing and maybe we
can do a little trapping or something.
And I was like,
well I can go one better.
We can still deer hunt
at the end of February.
So actually you've been to my place toy
or talk to my family's farm twice in the
last four or five years at this time
of the year when we went hunting,
you can go hunting at the end of
February with a land owner tag. Yeah.
How does that work?
Well,
it's private land hunt, so you're
not dipping into, you know,
they're not trying to
diminish the managers,
the harvest that might
happen on public lamb.
Right. And in, especially in our ear where
they're trying to reduce the deer herd,
um,
because of the CWD thing,
largely because it spreads faster than
more deer there are. Right. So, you know,
that's part of it. And I'm, I
believe that we have, you know,
that we have too many deer
in our area, um, you know,
in terms of a balanced
ecosystem. So, um, yeah.
So I think that I had to buy the
land owner tag, which was like $2.
And I remember Dodi like,
oh, he's going to step up.
And there were other guys
from board attacks and um,
and pat was there and I mean,
and Carl and we had seven or eight
or nine guys and Jody's steps up,
he's going to buy them
licenses.
It's like $18.
He's like,
that to me,
I've got the car door puts
a 20 [inaudible] hunted on
that trip for two bucks.
Yep, that's right. That's exactly what it
was. Yeah. That's incredible, man. Yeah.
You didn't need to have it.
A regular hunting license.
Then it was the land owner permit and
then these guys can have tags that the
deal.
Since you've been hunting since you were
a kid and both of you guys had been,
what,
what's your approach to
dealing with people like the
people that are going crazy
on my Instagram? People that don't
think that there's, that it's a,
a good thing to do to go hunting. They
think there's something evil about it.
They think there's something
wrong with it. This,
how do you deal with that disconnect?
I, I don't run into it very much. I mean
I do a little bit in Madison, but I,
as I said,
I people,
most of the people that I know that
don't hunt don't have a problem with me
doing it because of where you live. It's
a culture. But it's also, I mean Madison,
Wisconsin is a pretty,
you know,
liberal town and folks from
all over the world there.
And there's a certain fascination
with that. Actually the,
I've gotten a little more hot water.
D I'm talking about feral cats.
Rarely. That's something I've, I'm even
careful about bringing up that subject.
People yet real hunky about feral cats.
And I mean on the farm there
were always extra cats around.
And when you got to a point on the farm
where I used to do some contracts where
[inaudible] field and that
field of business we talked
about that first podcast
ever came on.
And so that's way more sensitive
subject then, you know,
hunting wild lands well. Right. And
people have a different connection to it.
And so friends of ferals is as big group
in Wisconsin and I know some friends of
ferals friends of ferals.
Yeah,
they're spaying and neutering
them and putting them back out,
back out and putting them back. Going
somewhere. Songbirds. Well, yeah,
I mean it's sort of sort of
that they also kill rodents.
This one friend of mine, guys that
run farms, I mean you gotta have cat,
you got lunch of cats like
Kiefer's get man, he's got,
every once in awhile he'll say, hey,
by the way, when we're up walking,
there's a cat up there. We
need to, I need a few less.
But I mean for just for
road and contamination and
a friend of mine who's, um,
yeah,
uh, I dunno, she belongs to
friends, friends of ferals. But um,
was one of the people who started chastise
me about talking about a gunny sack
and Iraq, which is how you get
rid of cats. Uh, extra cats,
gunny sack in a rock. You need throw
him in the water and just ground. Yeah.
Mild,
mild man's grandpa honestly
made him dispatch disposables
of a litter of puppies
that way. One time. Whoa. Anyway,
I made a comment about it somewhere
cause I actually, I said about, I
didn't even go into that. I just went
into songbirds and all that sort of stuff.
And she said, look, you know, on my,
and she's got the horses
and stuff and she said,
I might place all I have is feral cats
and they've all been spayed or neutered
and then I put them out there and yeah,
I get the whole thing about songbirds,
but in my area here in my place,
I'm taking care of it. You know,
they're not bothering songbirds are
not doing this. Then I'm like, yeah,
but that's not what's happening
everywhere else. Yeah. So you know,
the discussion ends up being, to my mind
at least the same kind of thing. Well,
how many, how many cats is enough?
How many deer or enough? Um, you know,
what's the balance that we're trying to
achieve here? What's the cause, you know,
we're the ones who made the problem.
Steve Sochi.
I mean they,
they killed,
they got the brushing government came
in and killed a bunch of stray dogs
because they had a real straight
dog rob. Yeah. And that made news
and healthy looking straight up.
Yeah.
But they shot a bunch
of dogs. See you've, uh,
you've had this conversation
many times, I'm sure. And I,
one of them I watched, uh,
in a a book signing that you had.
I thought it was, it was it books.
Yeah. Pt Guy came fascinating, you know,
and he was cool because he came to a,
a book event I did and sat
there through the whole thing,
can wait until the question period raised
his hand and then took me to task on,
on the idea of hunting and the,
that everything I was saying was just
like a justification for Wanda farm
animals, animal harm, animals to kill
animals. And I pointed out to him,
and it's something that I've said many
times and I'll say many times more.
So I think that people who,
who come at it with a perspective of
having an anti hunting perspective are
defending a set of ideas
that th th th th their concern for
animals, they're concerned for wildlife.
They're concerned for the wellbeing of
the natural world. They're defending us.
That animal,
a set of ideals that I know that
I understand better than they do.
I care more about it than they do.
I know much,
much more about it than they do.
I'm more vested in safe guarding the
things that they think their safeguarding
than they are. I mean,
I just am, you know, um,
I might not in my mind,
there a vast difference between an
individual wild animal and the idea or the
essence of that species.
Okay.
It's difficult for people to understand
an idea that, that they're saying like,
if you love this animal so much,
how could you kill it?
And it might be if you came down from
Mars, you cannot from outer space.
It might seem like this really
counterintuitive notion,
but because of the way we manage
wildlife purely in this country,
we have where we manage wildlife as
a public trust thing as a renewable
resource.
The funding for wildlife research,
the funding for enforcement,
the funding for habitat improvement in
this country is coming out of hunting.
License sales is coming out of excise
taxes that are on firearms and sporting
goods.
Guys that hunt our financing
to a large measure,
American wildlife particular, that's
particularly the case and even more,
I mean you could say that,
oh sure. At just inadvertent,
they don't mean to do that.
That need to be have a gun and they
want to have a hunting license,
but then you look at the work of
organizations like National Wild Turkey
Federation,
Rocky Mountain Elk Foundation,
ducks on limited Theodore Roosevelt
conservation partnership back country
hunters and anglers.
You're these groups that are hunter based,
habitat improvement,
hunter based wildlife organizations.
Those are the people
paying for the things in,
in financing the research
that gives the anti hunters even an idea
of what they're trying to defend it.
Like in this country,
it would not exist if we didn't
have some idea of publicly owned,
commodified wildlife where we recognize
that wildlife is has value and should be
maintained for the future.
You could have a bunch of
Rosie opinions about all that.
We would just take care of these
things because we should, and I agree.
It'd be great if we did,
but one of the best things that can
happen to a species now in contemporary
America, one of the best things that
can happen to it is that it's at,
it has a perceived value to hunters
because we want to make sure that our
resources are safeguarded and are going
to be around for a long time to come and
they're going to be round for
our kids and not talk about that.
It's altruistic or anything
else is based on pragmatism,
but we're taking care of our own
and we're handling our own issues.
Have you ever had a real legitimate
debate with someone who's an animal rights
activists where they sat down
for a long period of time,
like on a podcast and had a long form
conversation because never because no one
shallow, it's a shallow conversation
on their part. It's a shell
station on my part because like
if I sat down with someone, um,
I'd go into it just as,
as holy as they would just be like,
I'm never going to change my mind.
I don't think you would because that
conversation that you had with that guy at
that book signing shows that you've got
a pretty nuanced point of view when it
comes to this.
It's something you've considered.
I've tried to defend it from that point
of view in order to understand it better.
And the problem is there's nothing
there it goes, it gets shallow.
When you go into this idea
of overpopulation, you go
on the idea of what, what,
what are you gonna do?
You're gonna bring in predators.
Like how are you going to control
this population? Because if you don't,
you don't really love these animals
because the bottom line about game animals
when it comes to like things like deer
and elk and they must be hunted either by
wolves or by mountain lions or
by people because of they're not,
they're just going to fuck and they're
just going to overpopulate and they're
going to,
you get like something like the hand,
are you gay?
Are you wind up where you're at with
the Hamptons or where you're at with New
Zealand where then you have government
financed control efforts where you have
people willing to pay to do something
or you finance the, you know,
the sort of managed,
well I wanted, I would love to hear that
conversation. Like what is the, what's,
what's the contrary point of
view? It's, I did Bill Maher. No,
he's a fucking silly bitch.
Yeah, that guy is so silly.
He's friends with Anne culter and he's,
he's such a weird dude when
it comes to Sony things.
But the Pieta thing is a
knee jerk reactionary thing
that you can do if you're
getting all your food from
a fucking supermarket and
you're so not in touch with
the natural world, you're banging
playboy playmates at the mansion.
That's a fucking wildlife preserve
right there. That's a fence.
Didn't preserve well another
area, I'm sorry, go ahead.
But it's just,
I want to know what the point of view is.
What is the debate against,
because I've never seen it done.
I've never seen it success
talking about two different things,
but you're not really,
but I think that people would come and
they'd be talking about just suffering.
Okay. Animal suffering. I could never
look someone in the eye and say,
I could never look someone in the
eye and say that an animal is, uh,
willfully lending themselves to slaughter.
I could ever look someone in
the eye and say that, oh yeah,
hunting animals is painless procedure.
And so they have a thing where they value
if their primary thing is stopping any
level of suffering happening to
any individual sentient being.
And that's their goal.
My goal is just so different.
My goal is to have a managed,
when I say manage,
I'm just saying sustainable.
I'm not saying anything to
have a sustainable suite
of North American wildlife
that we can manage into the future for,
for myself and future
generations to enjoy.
And that we can leave the
country and leave the world in a,
in a better place.
The logic and than we found it. I think
that's a scientific perspective, Steve.
And when you're talking to Peter People,
the reason that chart, it's a religious,
you're talking about religious
fanatics in a way. Well,
it's a shallow thought thinking process
because they've only looked at it on the
surface and they've looked at it in a way
where they've conveniently ignored the
fact that these are animals that have
a finite lifespan and that the animals
that are traditionally
hunted by predators, human,
you're partnering with people
who are religious, but are they,
are they or are they just trying to,
are they just nice people that
haven't looked into it? Some people,
I think some of the Peta people and some
of the movement came when we realized
that a big Pharma and, and
uh, cause cosmetics industry,
and we're using animals for experiments
like chimpanzees and bunny rabbits with
lipstick. And a lot of people
said, you know, why are,
why are you making animals suffer on
these farms where you're using them for
their fur and using testing makeup on
them and they're going blind or you're,
you're seeing how a monkey reacts when
you take its baby or way you in the end,
the animal sobs or even,
and I don't know the extent of how
much HIV drugs have benefited from,
from experimentation on chimpanzees,
but I've read very heartbreaking accounts
of chimpanzees that are given HIV.
And they just saw because they feel
sick and they feel terrible and they
literally just put their head in their
hands and sob in a alone in some cases.
So you can understand all of us, I
think all of us go, wait a minute,
I can understand going, that's
not right. I don't want,
I don't want to buy products that are
tests on animals. And we all do that.
So I think some of the Peta movement
was fueled by that particular thing and
Doug Raises Doug raises beef cattle and
he just said that there's some cattle
practices that he's uncomfortable with.
Yeah.
And suddenly we were all drawing
lines and you're right, you know,
a lot of us could look like if you can
put some kind of shampoo and a rabbit's
eye and determined that that's not a good
recipe for shampoo and you could have
read the same conclusion in some way
that didn't involve animals suffering.
It's a, it's a potent argument. Yeah. But
a lot of trucks that save lives, they do.
You do. You start in a petri dish,
then you do test them on animals.
In the last group is a, is a,
is a controlled group of humans.
She read a book about this,
that that's what you do.
And the reason you test on animals is
because you have to see initially how it's
going to react in an organism
is complex as a, as a,
as an animal organism to see if it has
adverse side effects before you go on to
test it on to a human.
So it's a, but I can,
I can appreciate, like I
said, when somebody says,
if you're testing animals to see if you,
if somebody can look prettier,
I can see that being somebody
can have an objection.
So then it becomes a question of what,
what's,
what's worth what's worth testing
on animals. Yeah. And I, yeah,
I couldn't agree with more.
And Steve's right.
I've in my people will call you if you're
mistreating your animals in our area,
other people who have
animals and people who hunt.
And it's hard if you're mistreating
your animals, you get called out on it.
I'm in our area. People will
say, you know, wait a minute,
just like if you're doing poor, uh, uh,
management practices and your
fields and what not, people will,
will call you out on it.
Why aren't you doing contour stripping?
Or why aren't you taking
care of, you know, why don't
you take care of things. So,
you know, it's sort of an
extension of that. So it, you know,
in my view it ends up being, there's
a balance in all of this. And Yeah,
case by case, I, I'd go with you.
There's things, I mean, I don't,
I'm not worried about personally not
worried about I make up or that kind of
stuff.
So I don't think it makes
you shouldn't be,
you'd look beautiful.
There was a question about whether I
was going to something that literally,
I know, but the marketplace,
by the way, because of that,
that education that a lot
of the marketplace has said,
you know, you see a lot of,
how many products do you see that
not tested on animals? So not a ways.
The marketplace kind of went, you know
what? A lot of people, all of us went,
I don't want an animal.
I don't want that. Well,
there's big difference between testing
cosmetics, which is so frivolous,
or testing medicine, which you can save
your children. There's a huge difference.
In my eyes,
I don't have a problem with them.
Testing medicine that can save babies
are really, I'm sorry. I don't,
I like people more than I like animals.
I have to the whole vaccine.
I mean all of our major vaccines, man,
we wouldn't have, yeah, I have two dogs.
I have two cats. I love animals.
I fucking do animals. I love to
eat. I'm too though. I'll tell you a
surprising thing I saw one time did we?
Did we got to, do we have more? Do
we have a couple minutes? We're,
we're running out of steam here. I'll do,
I'll, well, I'll say it for next time.
We turn into a Pumpkin at three hours in.
We talked about a lot of this on the,
on the show eater. He gets on. Yeah.
Tomorrow night.
The show needs to be an hour.
Don't you think you show
needs to be an hour?
I'd love to see the show
because sports channel, the
candidate, Sarah Pailin, broad
fucking [inaudible] some
questions about that one too. But
sure. It's going to bring
attention to the network,
which is a great thing because
it's a great network and they,
they support that show,
which is the best show on television
all the time about going into hour.
And we talked about the
upsides and downsides. Don't
know, there's no downside,
there's no downside. There's
something really just, but I,
I've fallen in love a little bit hesitant.
Love with just how clean
and crisp 2020 well done.
How, how clean and crisp like a well done.
It's too good a show. Um, you're right.
That's flattery. Flattery,
44 minutes please.
It means in ease an hour
and needs no commercials.
That's great.
I couldn't agree with you more,
but I really got to get this in or Helen's
going to give me heck after awhile.
Helen's you can give me hell
and that is the show on.
But then also the show tomorrow night
is the second part of our episode.
And I honestly,
I'm excited to see it because I have no
idea what happens in this second part,
other than I know what
happened while we were there.
But what became a part of [inaudible]
what out of that 80 hours made
it really interesting that Steve,
you know what the first show we did,
Steve
warned me and said, well, you know, nobody
likes the way they come across. And I,
yeah, and I, and I was, it
felt exactly the opposite.
And then the other thing is that
you can download episodes on,
I can never remember the name.
Dot. Vtx Dot. Txt checks,
meat eater Dot v H X. Dot. TV.
That's exactly right. Okay.
Go there in the street. You can stream
and download. There it is right there.
Oh yeah, yeah. Awesome.
Fucking show. Live Bra.
It really is the best show on television.
And you know,
I get a lot of compliments about the show.
People that love it,
that I turned on to it and did not even
hunters. They have no desire to hunt.
They never want to hunt. They
just love it. It's a great show.
It's great narration. It's just,
it's a really special thing, man.
Joe Rogan is the best thing that
ever happened with the show.
There it is. Like, well, I'm honored. I'm
honored that you've had us on not once,
but twice. And that we're going to
do it again. And maybe with Collin.
You don't want to laugh. No, I
don't have to go into Alaska.
We're going to fuck up some boosts.
All right. It's happening. If I,
if there's room, I don't want them to
make room. We'll make another raft. We'll,
we'll, we'll buy some more land
from the Soviet Union you send.
Clifford is money [inaudible] conference.
Critter creations is like, I just, I
got to tell long stories and song story.
Tom, Clifford's a good man.
Follow Steve Rinella on Twitter.
It's Steven Rinella on
Twitter. Uh, you could fall.
Brian Callen on Twitter
as well. Br. Why n a n
c a l l e n n on Instagram.
Both guys.
Steve Brunello and Brian Callen Instagram.
Uh,
the show is on the sportsmans
channel. Find it. It's on direct TV.
It's six oh five on directv or 606,
605.
I think it's Channel Six oh five
on direct TV. Um, just find it.
Sportsmans channel. Uh,
it's an excellent show.
It's meat eater and it's on tomorrow
night will be the final episode,
Thursdays
and it's on drawn during the week. You
can, you know, run a search for it.
You're not an idiot. You
know how to do it. Doug,
during your fucking awesome human being.
It's been a pleasure.
You probably don't see me this
weekend. Yeah. Come see Brian counts.
You had caused my body at my buddy
Rodney Boehm, my buddy Rodney Boehm.
When my best friends lifelong,
a almost lifelong hunting partner.
Went to see Brian Cowen. He gave it
two thumbs up thumbs. He said, quote,
I laugh my dick off. I
know. I'll be there. Yeah,
he'll be there to talk.
Hey,
I'll be in the punchline then Minneapolis
next weekend. So lab your dicks off
the punchline in San Francisco, one of
the great comedy clubs in the country.
It's a perfect setup. I
love that fucking club. Uh,
I will be at the Verizon
Theater in Dallas on April,
March 14 with Ari Shaffir
and Duncan Trussell.
Then I'll be in Miami at the Jackie
Gleason theater on April 3rd with Tony
Hinchcliffe and then I'll be in Orlando
on April 18th at some fucking theater.
And then I could go to Joe rogan.net
for tickets figured out. All right.
I can't tell you everywhere
I'm going to be. Look,
we love the fuck out of you people.
We got a lot of crazy podcasts coming
up next week. We've got Louis thorough.
Um, I got, uh, what Robert Green, um,
and someone else, I don't know. I forget
who it is. They're going to be mad at me,
but forever fucking deal with it. All
right. Uh, thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to Tim, go to rogan.ting.com
save 25 bucks off of any device.
It's an awesome cell phone
company, an awesome company
to work with. We love them.
Also go to lumosity.com
lumosity.com forward slash
Joe and get your learn on Sun
Brain Games to a gym for the
mind and on it.com o n n.
I t use the Codeword Rogan and save 10%
off any and all supplements. All right,
we'll see you guys next week
and we love you. Take care of,
they're so cute.